time does fly time has two wings and one
beak like a airplane the two wings of
the plane container past and future
yesterday and tomorrow are the two wings
and The Barn at that front Peak is the
present and time flies like a plane
flies I may fly but you are the pilot of
the plane you have to decide where to
take your time you have to decide where
to invest your time you have to decide
how to utilize the time otherwise time
is just flying wherever it wants to
don't say I spend my time say I'm
investing my time to invest you look for
returns you say I spent my time it's
gone we say investment my time in my
career I invested my time in my study I
invested my time in association there is
a return RTI return on investment hey
seven Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggle
to stay afloat I quit I'm a business
partner and the thing that kept me
motivated kept me going was studying the
stories of famous successful
entrepreneurs and in their stories it
gave me the hope the drive the ambition
the thinking that maybe I can do it too
that extra bit of belief and I still
need their stories today and I'm honored
to share them with you here as well so
today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only enjoy
one of my friends used to say life is
unfair get used to it how many of you
heard that one
yeah and there's another friend of mine
who's a big businessman he said life is
unfair learn to negotiate
[Music]
statements one is saying life is unfair
get used to it like giving in and the
other saying life is unfair negotiate
work on something which one's right
which one's wrong both are right
life is unfair
learn to live with it
and things come and you can't change it
acceptance is the only way and life is
unfair learn to negotiate solve problems
and craft your own happiness right
[Music]
of the choice to craft our happiness
make a happy life remember if life gives
you a cactus you don't have to sit on it
you can do what you need to do with the
cactus
we can also learn to choose to live a
better life ladies and gentlemen life
can get finished anytime before life
gets finished complete your life by
adding these values to your life secrets
of living well is what makes your a
happy life
[Music]
one guy asked what is the difference
between the word complete and finished
the fellow said if you find the right
partner to get married to in your life
your life is complete
[Music]
if you get the wrong one
life is finished
with the right one catches you with the
wrong one life is completely finished
guys
but before life is finished let's
complete it we all have this desires and
we all keep fulfilling these desires we
have this wrong concept of Happiness let
me work hard let me get all the money
let me buy all of that stuff let me get
all the phones let me have those palaces
let me have my dream house let me have
my dream girl and I'll be happy
your dream
and there's nothing wrong with dreaming
there's nothing wrong with earning
and there's nothing wrong with having
but to dream that this is what will make
you happy
I'm sorry to say
recently in Silicon Valley I met a
friend of mine and his life is no
different
[Music]
after a certain while again
foreign
status game
it has no value it can't add more value
to your life it's all a status game
again don't get me wrong I'm not saying
don't earn
I'm just saying don't make the mistake
of equating your happiness with
something that only has
utility value of course when we're
talking about measurements we're
measuring in on in one way yes correct
so this the data and the statistics
would be in one space yes so in that
particular space we would say we list
here if we start measuring basing some
other yardstick as a statistic of
measurement probably have a different
whole different statistics available to
us nevertheless having said that I think
uh
I I often say
whether you drive a BMW or a Rolls-Royce
it's not the car that happiness it's the
journey
when the focus shifts overtly to the car
then the journey
you're compromising with your experience
car is important a good car is great no
problem but when your focus is overtly
on that you're compromising with your
journey
uh I say often it's not an iPhone or a
Samsung it's the quality of your
conversations on that phone that gives
you that experience of happiness but
when your attention moves from the
quality of conversations to the quality
of your phone overtly you're kind of
compromising with your experience
I often say that it's not the watch that
whether it's a Rolex or a disorder
whatever it is you know or uh Georgia
money whatever brand of Rado or a
Breitling whatever watch you wear I
really don't think it's the watch that
gives you that happiness it's how you
utilize the time on that watch that
gives you that experience but when your
focus shifts from utilizing your time to
your watch and flaunting that watch I
think we are compromising with our
experience I don't think it's the house
that's made of bricks and cement that
brings us the happiness with the whether
it's in Malabar Hill with the most fancy
uh Furnishings inside and a massive
space I think it's the quality of our
relationships in that house and
that bring this happiness the home that
brings us happiness so it's not India or
America or any place in the world it's
anybody
anybody who prioritizes things
achievements of things and starts
equating the quality of our their life
with those things we'll definitely have
a compromise standard of experience
whereas those who prioritize the quality
of their Journey the quality of their
relation and not saying the things
shouldn't be there absolutely not saying
that I'm just saying equating happiness
to that
is where the problem is where the
problem is because then you know today
and and it also comes from what's
considered a social social standard of
being being accepted with a social
standard being accepted as cool
today you're not judged for who you're
not accepted for who you are you except
for the car you drive or the of the area
you live in or the class of
uh an airplane that you fly on a flight
that you fly on so in a in a society
where the standards of your success are
so shallow
then the pressure to conform that if I
don't have this if I don't if I'm not at
this party I'm this form one the fear of
missing out I'm missing out big taste
big thing but who created it the
standard that we made that this is what
happens means
if we understand that there are Finer
Things that bring us happiness these
things have utility value let's use them
use the best stuff no problem
use the best stuff who say you don't
have a Rolls Royce but if you think
Rolls-Royce makes you happy I'm sorry
have the fanciest house who says don't
have it but the thing is the house that
makes you happy I'm not sure if bricks
and cement can make me happy also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there there is a materially poor man who
wants approves his Sage some say it was
the Buddha and asked him why am I so
poor
answered probably because you don't
practice generosity probably because you
don't practice charity amuse and a
little upset by the response the band
challenged charity I
anything
how can I practice charity
the savior of light who said you don't
have anything you have five Treasures
with you that you can definitely share
with others and give to others firstly
[Music]
you can share with others it's free and
it's awesome and it has an amazing
impact on others secondly you have your
eyes you can look at others with eyes
full of love and concern and make them
think
for third you have your tongue with your
tongue you can speak kind encouraging
appreciative uplifting words and make
people feel value
break joy and positivity using your
tongue and then you have your heart with
your loving heart you can wish well for
others and pray for the well-being and
happiness of others and lastly you
possess The Treasure of your body with
this body you can serve others do good
deeds help people in need help is not
always money a small caring gesture can
light someone's life up as well don't
of course the message is not that
financial resources are not needed we
live in a real world with real needs
moreover without caring for ourselves
it's hard to care for others the message
here is that even if we don't have the
required resources we can still be the
instruments of doing good in our own
ways according to our own capacities
make this world a
it is
that state of hopelessness if you don't
speak up
to further hopelessness and if you still
don't speak up
it can go to further hopelessness
and so bad
I saw my aunt
burn herself
to death I saw my friend's son
his medical
marksheet being author of the University
kept next to his dead body
foreign
well
Maybe
my aunt would still be with me
my friend's son would still be doing his
postgrad and contributing to the World
by healing other people with his medical
expertise
I have an humble appeal
look for that friend if you have one
blessed are you open your heart on a
regular basis if you don't have one look
for one and invest in that relationship
my meditation is before bed my
meditation is a gratitude practice like
prayer prayer every evening before I go
to bed is a practice of gratitude
recounting all the things that happened
in the day and being grateful for
everything that happened consciously
practicing gratitude and eventually it
just becomes a part of you anyways yeah
and the first thing in the morning as
soon as I am up is also beginning my day
with gratitude and then of course I have
a specific time for meditation as well
which I spend like an hour and a half
every day problems happening challenges
happen struggles happen issues happen
misunderstandings have
Financial crunches happen markets go
down and that happens all of that
happens
happiness
doesn't happen
we have to make it happen because right
things don't happen
you have to make the right things
happen
Fitness is the right thing doesn't
make Fitness
happen any of you want to lose any
weight
oh thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that guy
thank you
losing weight doesn't happen you have to
make it happen not reacting when you're
angry
shutting that Bloody mouth up doesn't
happen
you have to make it happen
you have right things don't happen
automatically
only wrong things happen automatically
right things you have to make them
happen guys
[Music]
they don't happen like that
well one man was asking his wife and
you're like really really
what do you do to
do yeah
[Music]
he's asking his wife really like really
wild at me what do you do to vent out
your anger she said I cleaned the
commode in the house
so he said why do you agreeing to come
out to enter your anger on me she's like
leave it with your toothbrush
so the next morning there's some special
effects in your mouth
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll tell you what
I'll tell you what we all react in our
own ways she has a toothbrush
and you have your own ways
to lose it
ladies and gentlemen
not reacting
and shutting this up
doesn't happen
you have to make it happen
saying oh sorry when somebody hurts you
of forgiving somebody when somebody
doesn't happen
you have to
make it happen I'll tell you what
the nature of problems is that it
consumes our mind
am I in a tooth which is hurting I don't
know if somebody's had their fingers
stuck in the edge of the door and the
door slammed
good habits it hurts like hell
and then the pain is just so
all-consuming the mind just focuses so
much on the pain right I think it's just
the nature of problems that it draws our
mind towards them
like the tongue going towards the cumin
sea in my tooth when it was stuck it's
like Gravity the law of gravity if we
put this bottle up and put it up here
and drop it it's going to just be pulled
down yeah drag down by the power of
gravity I think there's a power of
gravity existing within us as well
they're just natural for us to be
dragged down
to our issues our problems
right to everything that's negative
I think being being
negativity is so normal it's like
gravity
[Music]
you know how to do anything
but if I were to pull water up from the
ground floor to the eighth floor
I need a mortar correct to work against
gravity and I need conscious hard work I
have to bring it there so it's so
natural for the mind to feel negative
and go towards the problem
but if I have to look at 31 other teeth
I have to make a conscious choice to
take my tongue away right if I have to
pull the water down from the ground
floor to the eighth floor I have to put
a pump to pull it off it's not easy work
it's hard work right but hard work pays
off that's when you like look at really
saying okay this is fulfilling me now
you know that and and I I definitely
don't want to impose this this principle
of gratitude in a
in a unrealistic way on people because
sometimes misery is so intense
absolutely
you know when troubles are small
small consciously look at the brighter
side of life
you know but sometimes troubles are just
so intense and massive and they seem to
be like mountains
unmoving unshakable
mountains they just stand there for ages
and decades
[Music]
how in such a situation wouldn't it be
so violent
fully impose the principle of gratitude
on a person
whose life is so acutely absorbed and
intense misery
right you know I call that toxic
positivity
it's toxic
it's not natural so what does one do
really yeah it just yeah it's such a
situation
well they're just so
overwhelmingly painful you know my take
on it is it's hard to look at the
brighter side when this intense pain
there
but at the same time I also feel if we
are consumed by negativity with that
pain and that problem and occupying our
mind
we lose the ability to deal with it the
way we are meant to
correct so if we could seek help if I'm
not able to see it we could seek help of
somebody it could be professional help
personal help friends whoever it could
be she could seek help to be able to
shift our attention to even the tiniest
things
so that that little positivity becomes
the anchor to deal
in an interview on a television show The
Anchor asked the tennis Legend Martina
Navratilova
how do you maintain your focus and
manage to keep playing even at the age
of 43 the instant response that she gave
was mind blowing she said well to be
honest the ball has absolutely no idea
about how old I am plus the need to
focus is only for 10 of the match for
the rest 90 percent I don't even have to
focus in a typical tennis match the
players spend less than 15 percent of
their time hitting the ball during a
round of goals golfers spent less than
20 percent of their round swinging at
the golf club at an American football
the ball is actually in play for only
six percent of the game sports
psychologist Garrett Kramer says that a
key factor to performing well in sports
and I suppose in life as well is your
ability to control the quality and the
quantity of your internal dialogue a
performance can reach its peak and we
can realize our Highest Potential when
the internal interference it stops us
from giving our best is minimized and
eventually stopped isn't it said that
any game including the game of life is
played on a six inch course
the space between our ears if we can
master that space we can Master any
space in life Walking With Lions
casually can probably be easy when the
lions are tamed when we have experts who
can deal with them around us and take
charge of any untoward situation that
may happen otherwise we all know that
the lion is an extremely powerful strong
and a ferocious animal and we dare not
go close to a lion but the same lion
with all its strength power ferocity and
influence as the king of the jungle can
be helplessly Disturbed and frustrated
any guesses who can frustrate a life
a tiny little bird
sometimes a bird may come and sit on the
back of the Lion
cratch it
tickle it a passionate and to say
nothing of driving away the bird the
lion cannot even reach it at times and
even if somehow the lion can reach it
the bird just flies away ladies and
gentlemen we as human beings
have our power in the society that we
live in as well our power comes from
money position Fame influence Talent
skill
but just like the lion has that bird
which can disturb him we have that one
bird which can leave us helpless
hopeless
Sleepless extremely frustrated and
Disturbed that Berg which is a constant
companion is our mind
the greatest power in the world
is not money or riches positional
influence the greatest power in the
world is our ability to take charge of
our mind and focus it on and direct it
to where we want it to be and not get
directed by the mind all mental health
issues depression pressure negativity
anxiety stress loneliness worry
come from the inability to deal with the
mind spirituality and meditation is that
practice which helps us to take charge
of the mind to train it and be empowered
to live a life which is peaceful Mindful
and joyful a tortoise will withdraw its
limbs when it feels intimidated when it
feels insecure when it feels fearful of
being attacked
but when the tortoise finds itself in a
surrounding which is protected and
secure the tortoise will bring all of
its limbs out
I think even in our relationships when
we feel the fear of being judged the
fear of being used
the fear of being rejected we withdraw
ourselves from people in our
relationships don't we very true but
when we feel protected when we feel
secure when we feel ourselves in a
surrounding in an environment where
there is trust where there is
understanding where we are treated with
respect when we are treated with love
that's when we bring ourselves fully out
to connect to that person we are happy
confiding to them we are happy to speak
to them they're happy to deeply connect
with them and I think that's really what
makes a relationship really meaningful
and happy isn't it so yes a tortoise
does teach us that we should look for
those people in our relationships who
can give us that surrounding we can
bring out most of our the best best out
of us and we should try and avoid those
surroundings where we feel fearful of
being judged you know and being used in
which case we need to withdraw like the
tortoise withdraws its limbs within its
shell ladies and gentlemen if we have
problems in our life it only means there
is life and we need to celebrate
yes indeed the problems May differ like
I said the flavors may vary the
magnitudes May Vary some have different
kinds of problem to different magnitudes
and we may have a completely different
nature of problems to a different
magnitude how many of you here have
eaten something when your mind wanted it
thank you very much how many of you here
have said something to someone when
you're just mind wanted it
thank you how many of you have walked
into a shopping mall or into a branded
store to buy something when your mind
said it
I think we live in a world where we have
all become
excuse my jargon
servants and slaves to our mind
what if we learn to reverse the
situation and rather than being slaves
to the Mind learn to be Masters to the
Mind where rather than the mind being in
our control we are in control off
our minds
the
state of the world that we are in today
however
is because like Mahatma Gandhi said
there is enough in the world
for everybody's need
but it's not enough
for one man's greed
its lack of self-control that makes
people greedy
it's lack of self-control that makes us
consumers consuming consuming consuming
consuming at the cost of all of those
resources that nature provided us so
that we can sustainably live and create
a legacy of sustainability for the
future Generations
unfortunately for us however
look at it that way
consumption is not a problem we need to
live in the world we need to consume but
should that consumption be at the cost
of everything that provides us and
everything that gives us you know and
which is why I do believe that when we
are slaves and servants to the mind
we are consumers
but when we are Masters to our mind we
are contributors one of the sustainable
development goals of the United Nations
is responsible production and
consumption
be responsible in consuming and be
responsible in producing many of us love
eating good food
as fancy as the preps may look and as
delicious as they may be they get
digested once they enter into our system
and the body needs to throw The Unwanted
waste out in a day failing which can
cause illness
there is nothing in the world that can
quench our thirst more and make us feel
more refreshed than water yet if the
body doesn't throw that water out in a
couple of hours that retained water
can be the cause of illness I once saw a
very elderly yoga teacher teach her
students breathing techniques she asked
them to breathe in and hold their breath
but elderly as she was
she happened to fall asleep
the students who respected her a lot
were unable to hold their breaths any
longer but didn't even want to disobey
her
finally as they were gasping one of them
walked up to her and woke her up as she
got up she said and now
breathe out as funny as this may sound
the air we breathe in can be held for no
more than a few minutes and if it's not
thrown out
we may die
isn't this principle true for our
negative emotions as well emotional hurt
grudges jealousy feelings of hatred
Revenge anger can make our minds toxic
yet we continue to hold them in our
systems only leading to so many
psychological and consequently physical
disorders the body has a system to
remove unwanted food water or air
without us even being aware of it how we
wish there were an automatic Arrangement
that could throw negative feelings and
emotions out as well
that's not how it works with the mind we
have to consciously work on purging
these toxic emotions out of our inner
systems and here are three suggested
ways to get these feelings out first
write your feelings down on a piece of
paper and tear it into pieces or burn it
into ashes
practice doesn't necessarily solve the
problem but allows us to express
ourselves and release the negative
energy at least temporarily
second open your heart and confide into
someone close and trustworthy sharing
our feelings can not only Enlighten the
heaviness we feel but we may also
receive support and guidance to deal
with our negativity
third the most powerful of course is
adopting a spiritual practice which can
help us cleanse our Consciousness and
give us the inner strength to fight
these Tendencies always remember that
it's not the glass of water which is
only a couple of grams in weight
hurts our hand it is the duration for
which we hold it
quicker we keep it down
the better it is for us the man during
his travels once came up to a mountain
where he found a lady meditating under a
tree quite intrigued by her presence in
a solitary place like this he asked her
what are you doing here alone in such a
secluded place the lady replied that she
had a lot of work to do on that mountain
a little amused the man asked a lot of
work I cannot see anything around you
here what do you have to do up here on
this mountain the lady replied we'll
have to train two Hawks and two Eagles
teach two rabbits discipline one snake
motivate a donkey and aim a lion and if
I might ask you where are they I don't
see any of them up here question the man
sir you'll never be able to see them
because they all live inside here within
me set the lady the Hawks stare at
everything that comes to me people good
or bad situations good or bad things
good or bad and have to work hard to
train them to focus on the good side the
Hawks represent the vision behind my
eyes and the two eagles with their
clothes can hurt and Destroy I have to
train them not to hurt those Eagles are
my hands that need to do something
constructive for the world and not
create or engage in anything hurtful or
destructive rabbits are very Swift and
they want to go wherever they want to go
I have them to not just run around but
run in the right direction after all
what use is the speed if there is no
Direction the rabbits represent my feet
and I always want them to go in the
right direction in life the donkey is
often lethargic and at times acts very
stubborn I need to motivate it to
continue on with its work my mind is
exactly like the donkey it takes up
something but then uses the enthusiasm
to continue and also can be very
obstinate at times a lot of hard work
goes into dealing with this donkey sir
to plead with it to keep going on and on
the most difficult to tame however is
the snake although it is locked in a
strong cage with 32 bars it's always
ready to sting bite and poison anyone
nearby I have to discipline it and that
is my tongue I have one lion too oh how
proud how vain he thinks he's the king I
have to tame him and show him his real
position and that's my ego so now you
see my Deezer I have lots of work to do
up here on the mountain ladies and
gentlemen all of us have lots of work to
do as well internal work that can
transform our external life so let's
stop gossiping let's stop criticizing
let's stop evaluating and judging others
let's start looking at and working on
our own lives isn't it said yesterday I
was trying to be clever so I wanted to
change the world today I'm trying to be
wise so I know that I need to change
myself I don't think
the past generation had a buying
capacity that we have today
I don't think the past generation had an
investment capacity that we have in the
world out there today
think we have scaled up
we have reached and escalated ourselves
up to the 29 floors and I believe we
should keep getting better and reaching
for better in scaling up more and more
and more technology wise
good heavens
technologically I don't think we have
been ever so globally connected as today
I don't think so
there's never been a time in the history
of creation
that the world has been so globally
connected
how people know each other how people
can be so connected to each other
physically miles apart thousands of
miles apart
it's sharing a very close Monday
how many of you have done made I've ever
had a religious past or something
a religious fast you know in today's age
you don't have to fast from food and
water
is
this is what God will tell us
now hand on my heart hand on my heart I
must tell you we have scaled up and I
can go on and on and on describing how
we have gone up the 29 floors of success
I'm just wondering
is there a possibility
that we may have left the key
to True fulfillment
satisfaction
contentment
way too behind
like my friend and my host left the key
in the car I'm not sure
I don't see people any happier than the
last generation I see people more
miserable than the last generation
I don't see people any happier than the
last generation I see people more
stressed than the last generation I
don't see people any satisfied in the
last generation I see more people more
anxious than the last generation
I don't feel people I don't see people
most peaceful and stable than the last
generation I see people more Disturbed
than the last generation
I saw a t-shirt the guy was wearing a
t-shirt it's you know these t-shirts are
these funny slogans one one of the
stations had a slogan saying please do
not disturb
underneath was written in begged letters
already Disturbed
that's what I'm trying to say
with all the success that you have
achieved
[Music]
are you satisfied
with all the escalation with all the
fast pace at which you've gained what
you have today
do you feel fulfilled
with all what you have at your beck and
call people to work under you people to
report to you
guys looking at you and saluting you man
you made it there
do you feel there's some pin prick
somewhere
you know a question that needs to be
addressed and believe me you I'm not
saying we shouldn't scale up did I say
that
I'm not saying we shouldn't go up the 29
flows did I say that
I'm just saying as we are reaching the
29 floors can we afford to forget the
key
as you're going up I'm saying why 29
climb up to 290.
I'm a very ambitious man and I teach
people to be ambitious
I'm saying why the heck are you thinking
of thinking small
why the heck are you thinking 29 flows
that's adlc that's mediocracy
you shouldn't think small
we should never think small
you should think big absolutely big to
grow up to not 29 290 floors up
but should it be at the cost
that's my question that's all I'm asking
should it be at the cost
of taking a key
along which is why I always like to
speak about these two terms one is
called being successful
and second is called feeling successful
astrology
sastra
palmistry
parrot cards
tarot cards
everyone's wanting to know
the secret
that life holds
for future
how many of you would like to take a
journey into the future
thank you how many of you would be
interested to know how long you would
live
there are some courageous Souls
how many of you would like to know who
your life partner would pay
foreign
oh my God
technology is such a big thing I was
coming from some country and it was a
free flight 75 of us
and one man was totally drunk I was
sitting there he comes up to me and said
when did Jay
foreign
one guy came up to an astrologer
and said problems
foreign
[Applause]
I'm sure all of us are looking for
answers of what would happen with us
isn't it
one who's born will be dead
one whose date will be born
we have no control
I didn't have any control over how I was
born and where I was born
I don't have any control over what my
looks were what family I was born in
what country I was born with what what
social economic class I was born and I
had no control over it
and I must say that we truly have no
control over when life ends and how we
die
just Cardinal Facts of Life
but there's something that we have
control over
which can make life beautiful
therefore I generally say life is a
journey between two alphabets
be
Andy
where b stands for birth
and d stands for death
what is in control is between the
alphabets B and D is an alphabet called
C
between B and D is a c and that c is
choice we can all learn to choose as we
live our lives we can all learn to
choose not to prove but to improve
we can all learn to choose not to react
but to respond
we can all learn to choose how not to
get affected by what's happening in our
lives all around us and it does
our life is a matter of choices Live
Well
it won't easily go wrong
you can't change your situations you can
change your response ladies and
gentlemen how can every morning be the
same how can every afternoon be the same
how can every evening be the same how
can every day be the same
foreign
[Music]
happy morning
happy morning sir happy morning how are
you doing this morning happy morning
good morning
[Music]
you can say good morning because
sometimes there may be nothing good in
the morning
nothing good in that day
so now the term is Happy morning
because whether the morning is good or
not you can still choose to be happy
right
whether it's good or not it cannot be a
choice
whether the morning is good or not for
you cannot be a choice it's not a choice
for you
when you wake up some virus may enter
into your head and you get up with a
high fever it's not a child you have
whether the morning is good or not is
not in your control whether the
afternoon is good or not is not in your
control the evening is not enough
control whether the day is good or not
is not in your control but whether you
can be happy in that moment well you can
choose to be
when people smile it doesn't mean things
are going good
it just means that they've chosen to
smile they
this is narrative that the more you have
the more successful you are but I know
people who have a lot and have serious
mental health issues I consider that a
failure
I know about we we left we we just lost
Mr rakeshwala and we remember what he
said remember his words he said I have
about five billion dollars worth
I only wish God Gave Me Better Health if
I have all the money in the world and my
mental health is at stake my emotional
health is at stake my physical health is
at stake my spiritual health is at stake
my social health is at stake am I
successful
so let's not make one element of success
as success yes achievements and
financial success is a very crucial
element but not be element you know a
balance
and having paid attention to all of
these aspects is when we can truly call
ourselves successful like one gentleman
asks someone you know uh what is the
difference between the word complete and
finished
said well if you find a right partner in
your life to get married to your life is
complete
if you get the wrong one
your life is finished
but if the right one catches you with
the wrong one in life is completely
finished
sorry about that sorry
but I think I think when we're looking
at we want to complete everything isn't
it and which is precisely why it's
important we complete our definition of
success too
by including those elements that are
important for our life not just for our
lifestyle achievements and monies about
lifestyle emotional mental social
spiritual health is about our life and
lifestyle and life must go hand in hand
that's when success is completed and if
you're looking at three elements which
we really must look at whatever aspect
of success if you want to be successful
and number one is we shouldn't be goal
focused we should be process focused I
see a lot of guys go to the gym
you know uh any of you guys go to the
gym
okay brilliant any of you want to reduce
your weight a little bit
oh God my God is
that guy needed a whack trust me you
know now when you go to a gym I see
these younger guys going to a gym and
doing bicep curls that's the only
exercise they focus on
because that's the way to girls
show your guns so you'll see them go to
the gym I'm going to put the microphone
down
guys
we'll do this
and then sweep
the biceps don't lift the weight at all
it's the body that's lifting the weight
and in the mirror they're saying
[Laughter]
they should be originating their biceps
and just picking their weight with the
biceps right so when you're goal focused
you don't get the goal when you process
Focus you reach there so whatever it is
in your life that you want to achieve
focus on the process the more consumed
You Are by the process the greater
chances you reach the goal then just
focus turning on the goal and not on the
process we all have that villain in our
life right
also we call them
because sometimes it's a perception that
they have in sometimes the reality that
their Village do all of that person in
us in our stories we all have that one
person in our stories
[Music]
everybody has that one person in their
lives
that I want to give you just one thing
so much can be said on the topic like as
it's a whole discussion on itself
someone
that's not necessarily for them
when you forgive someone that is for you
for your peace
so that you come to peace with things
[Music]
sometimes what they do doesn't even
deserve forgiveness
you know what I say often forgive or not
forgive is a very individual choice
you want to live in peace however
it is imperative that we let go of what
we have held in our minds and you pent
up in our minds because small or less
this phone may be what 200 grams 300
grams if I hold this phone on my palm
it's going to hurt me a little bit for a
while if I hold it for two hours it's
going to hurt my wrist a lot if I hold
it for an entire day it's going to start
numbing my wrist I hold it for an entire
week without putting it down it's going
to paralyze my wrist
it's not what you hold and how long you
hold it's not worthy old and how heavy
it is but so how long we hold it so to
keep down that phone
is some compassion to my own wrist
not to the phone
so what I hold for somebody is like that
phone
it's not so much for them
it's for my own peace
it's for my own my own coming to terms
with my own Joy you know
and and
[Music]
surely mean forgetting it
we've always been told forgive and
forget forgive and forget forgive and
forget no you know what when we are
talking about forgiving and forgetting
forgiving is about stopping that person
that person's actions that person what
that person's doing
to influence how we feel now
memories are not going to be easily
erased
memories of what people have done to us
do you think memories can be easily
erased
you know what when I take am I okay to
take a picture of you all of you guys
story please
[Music]
right it's gone
and now if I go to my trash in this
and deleted its permanently deleted from
the memory correct
but that's because this is a form
any impression that is made on the SIM
card or on the memory of this phone in
Sanskrit is called a sumskar
samskar means an impression that is made
on something it goes through this lens
and leaves an impression on there
but these impressions are very easy to
delete at the Press of a delete button
is got from your memories
guess what ladies and gentlemen
in our life through what we read here
what happens to us so a lot of some
scars happening on this memory here
and they are not easy
to delete
so I'm not even that's why I said I'm
not even asking you to reread them you
need to be so elevated spiritually to be
able to just go leave it all behind we
are not we are people living in the real
world
foreign
don't allow that person Now to control
your peace
let go
but we are also simultaneously saying
that there is going to be that side
and every single time you see that
person
imagine an abuser coming in front of
those businesses abused
[Music]
to trigger everything back again
all right
everything back again and that's
precisely why during the course of my
talk I had said
forgiveness saying oh sorry it doesn't
happen we have to make it happen by
shifting our attention elsewhere
a I'll stay away from my triggers which
trigger that memory but if that memory
does come to me and I feel angry I feel
hurt I feel everything coming to me I'll
be compassionate to my own self and say
it's okay
it's okay be compassionate to yourselves
compassion is not just meant for others
so be self compassionate
if you feel anger you feel anger if you
feel hurt you feel hurt you go through
what you go through you go through what
you go through don't stay there because
it's ruining your life who's this
teacher in London she's in London she
came to the class and she asked all the
kids a question
I want to give you all an assignment I
want all of you to write on your
notebooks
answers to this question
what do you want to be when you grow up
and the obvious answers Engineers
doctors actors and nowadays social media
influencers
YouTubers you know like insta Stars
nowadays the things that change
engineering
[Music]
now it is
YouTuber
and nowadays narratives have changed
people say Monk
can you believe that
change of narrative
because this is like monk swag
I'm like a monk with a swag
so nowadays youngster saying could just
open there
change of narrative
so everybody wrote their answers one oh
I was sitting in the class he hadn't
written it was taking a little longer
But the teacher came to the boy and said
you've not written your answer this is
finishing did you say what do you want
to be when you grow up the boy said I
want to be happy
the teacher looked at him
gobsmacked
like Gob smacked
she said look son I don't think you
understood the assignment
[Applause]
the boy turned to the teacher and said
look ma'am I don't think you understood
life
because if you would have understood
you would know well
[Music]
that what you want to be
when you grow up
is happy and the legendary boy who gave
this legendary answer was none but John
Lennon from the Beatles
he was the one who gave this answer
when you turn 22 what do you want to be
but you want to turn 62 what do you want
to be
when you turn a billionaire what do you
want to be
when you reached the peak of your career
what do you want to be
they're very simple
a very simple answer
we all want to be
happy the lady named Maria lived with
her mother in a small apartment she was
not too young nor too old not too short
not too tall either not particularly
beautiful nor was she ugly
Maria was just an average woman she
worked as a secretary at a large company
and her life was pretty boring and
mundane no one at work ever paid any
attention to her and those who did
considered her to be as boring as her
life was
one morning on our way to work Maria saw
a new hat shop that had opened just down
the street out of curiosity she walked
in in the shop was a lady with her
daughter would come to pick a hat for a
girl and a couple of other customers who
were trying different hats
Mario also tried a few hats until she
found one she truly liked
put it on and it looked really nice the
first one to notice was the little girl
who exclaimed mommy look how pretty that
woman looks with the hat on
the mother said ma'am I must say this
hat looks awesome on you
another man in the shop also came up to
Maria and said ma'am you look lovely
with that hat on Maria went to the
mirror she looked at herself and for the
first time in years she liked her own
look
smiling she went to the counter and
bought the Hat as she walked outside a
new world revealed itself to her like
never before she never before noticed
the colors of the flowers around her or
smelt the scent of the fresh air even
the sounds of the cars and people on the
road sounded like a harmonious Melody
she walked as if she was Drifting On A
Cloud with a sock being played in her
heart when she passed by the same coffee
shop she walked by every morning a young
handsome man
got out to her hey you're looking
gorgeous can I buy a cup of coffee for
you she blushed kept walking
floating on the cloud of a new found joy
when she got to the office building the
doorman opened the door and wished her
good morning never before had he even
noticed her the people in the elevator
asked her the floor she needed and
pressed the button for Maria her
colleagues at the office as it's seeing
her for the very first time praised her
on how lovely she looked that day
the manager asked her out to lunch to
talk about how she felt at work when
this extraordinary work day was over she
decided to take a cab back home instead
of the bus as soon as she put her hand
up two taxis stopped she took the first
one and sat in the back seat thinking
about the magical day she had had
how her life felt so different than
changed thanks to the new hat when she
got home her mom opened the door the
sight of Maria took her breath away
Maria she said surprised you're looking
fabulous today your eyes are all lit up
like when you were a little girl yes Mom
said Maria it's a whole thanks to my new
pet I had the most marvelous day in
years
you had asked the confused mother which
hat are you talking about
Maria panicked she touched her head only
to realize that the hat that had changed
her life
is not there
she tried remembering where she may have
left it in the cab
no at lunch
I don't think so at the office not at
all she thought of the store where she
had bought it
how she had noticed it for the first
time how she had put it on her head how
she had gone to pay for it at the
cashiers
oh my goodness she remembered how she
had put it on the counter to get her
purse out to pay and how she had
gotten it
there
on the counter and then she had walked
out
right there to the street
Atlas
yet
glowing
ladies and gentlemen it wasn't the
external hat that made Maria's day great
it was the quality of her internal
dialogue that transformed how she felt
our internal dialogue can enslave us
into a horrible routine life or can
liberate us making our life full of
Gusto energy passion and joy
change your hat inside today and look at
the magic of how the outside had simply
simply adds on
to your already existing
gorgeous
inner beauty ladies and gentlemen in the
modern era we have mastered the art of
being successful
I'm not sure if we have mastered the art
of feeling successful and there's a big
difference between being successful and
feeling successful being successful is
quantum numbers
[Music]
and feeling successful is quality
as you get all the numbers that you
dream for as you get all the numbers
that you work hard for that you get all
the numbers that you're passionate about
are you also looking at quality with the
quantity
so yes climbing up is about the quantity
but carrying the key along is about the
quality of your lives and I think it's
such a crucial aspect even if you're
looking at enhancing your performance
only if you lead a quality life can you
enhance effectively
otherwise a stressed out guys more than
a stress than is God
Optimum performance what the hell
when the mind is not in place what are
we talking about Optimum performance cut
Corners you know
cut corners
being successful
is about what others think of you
feeling successful is what you think
about your own life everybody thinks
these are ft guys you know
everybody thinks these guys are driving
big cedents
everybody girl thinks oh gosh these guys
are making money man
everybody thinks you are doing
exceedingly well
what are you thinking about yourself
what are you thinking about your life
who cares a heck what others think about
our lives
what do we think about our lives or the
question that we all need to ask
ourselves
so I'm not against being successful for
sure I'm saying while we are trying to
be successful we need to live our life
in a way that we can also feel
successful so today
this evening
afternoon rather
I would give to you two keys
one how to feel successful in your work
and second how to be successful in your
work
so I'm gonna give you the key when you
walk up
but I'm also going to talk to you about
how to reach 290. from 29.
both ways both are important go up and
carry the key along but first I'll talk
about the key because that's my home
ground
you know that's my homegrown you can't
catch me on the wrong foot there
hopefully
okay how many of you were good at Max
okay great how many of you are terrible
at Max
[Music]
how many of you didn't care any less
good or bad okay
sometimes they say match stands for
mentally affected teachers harassing
students
full form of match you know this is
harassing us with this mathematics I'm
an electrical engineer so mathematics
came really easy to me it was a part of
my life I you know it's like in every
cell of your body there's bats for
engineers one teacher came to a
classroom once and said to the kids if a
ship is sinking a frog is croaking and
potatoes are 20 rupees a kilo gas what
my age is
[Music]
the student said ma'am can you come back
with a question please the teacher said
well a ship is sinking a frog is
croaking and potatoes are 20 rupees for
a kilogue is what my age is one student
raise this hand and said 32 madam 32.
she said you spot on man but how did you
get that right like sometimes you find
child prodigies
you know they're like Masters and
singing or dancing or writing or
whatever they do
they keep people you see two-year-old
kids when their hands work go on a piano
Spellbound now don't tell me that he
could learn that and master it at that
age
don't tell me
a two-year-old can't master the alphabet
tell me that he mastered it by learning
it in fact nobody taught it to him
he got it
he got it now when you say he got it
don't call it genetic how does g how do
genes give you a music skill
you know how
so I know kids young little kids who are
like prodigies in what they do at one
and a half at two
it's absolutely phenomenal and then now
where is where is faith and belief here
it's rational logic that this guy has it
it's not come from learning it's not
come from Reading nobody imparted to him
must come from somewhere how can they be
in effect Without a Cause
and I can't see an immediate cause right
now so there has to be a remote cause
before this right you know what I mean
whether I call it karma whether I call
it whatever but I I can't accept an
effect without a cause it's against my
rational thinking you know so now you if
this gentleman this little boy or little
girl he or she has this incredible
Talent
we call it the common parlance is he or
she is God gifted absolutely absolutely
God Gifted Man look at Skye
not learned look at how they're doing it
so that's that to me is called luck call
it Destiny call it karma Call It
Whatever I didn't get I didn't grab it I
got it Matthew McConaughey
when he got the Oscar
he said something phenomenal I loved it
in fact it's written in the book as well
he first of course thanked God thanked
his wife thanked his father thanks Mom
and he said I want to thank God
[Music]
but I want to thank God because
opportunities are not given by the human
hand I didn't seek a lot and it came to
me
how do I explain it there's a million
other people who are seeking they don't
get it that's right and I don't see can
I get it what am I going to explain it
by you know you know what I mean now
what that little one does with that
Talent
or what's that what this gentleman does
or this lady does with the opportunity
that has come
is my free will or my choice whether to
drive right to drive left or to not
drive right correct but the car
for a lot of people was given correct
now uh that Free Will part is where I
often like to quote I say I don't know
who said it but it's a beautiful quote
it says when hard work
Beach Talent when talent doesn't work
hard
absolutely you know so now the talent
came to you when you were two but if you
don't do nothing with it
has no meaning it has no meaning so you
didn't drive the car you grossly abused
the Fantastic gift the car that you were
given yes correct and then the others
may not get a car like that but they
have their own car
which they now need to identify that's
called self-discovery yes to be able to
identify what's the car you've been
given
what's what's it that you've been gifted
with and everybody has been gifted with
something the one thing that I've
learned over the years is that we are
also different our lives are so
different our situations are so
different our backgrounds are so
different our upbringing is so different
the Journey of our life up until now for
each one of us is so different
compared to somebody else and therefore
it's so important that we don't judge
our own life all the lives of others by
comparing them with someone else's life
here's an example
if Mr a can Sprint a distance of 10
kilometers in one hour whereas Mr B
covers the same distance in one and a
half hour which one of the two would you
call faster and healthier
the answer obviously would be Mr a
now what if I tell you that Mr a had a
prepared track to run on when Mr B
written by walking on a Sandy path I
think an answer will not change and we
probably think that Mr B is fitter and
let's say we come to know that actually
Mr a is 75 years old while p is only 20.
here we go our answer changes again and
we now think that the 75 year old Mr a
is healthier guess what Mr aov 60 kg
where is Mr B 125 kg which makes it
really hard for him to run who do you
think did well oh my goodness now we
correct ourselves again as we favor Mr B
the more we get to know about the
strengths and limitations of Mr A and B
respectively
our opinions and judgments about who is
better keep changing and isn't life like
that as well guys we form opinions about
others so quickly so hastily so
impulsively so superficial without
knowing much about them or their
situations we end up judging people
labeling people and miss out on
connecting to and encouraging the
immense potential that they may have
is not the same for all some may not be
as talented as others but may get better
opportunities and thus scale up very
fast whereas others despite being super
talented keep struggling just to make
the ends meet
some may have more resources whereas
others can't find any source to fall
back on each one has different problems
and so no one solution can work for all
just like one size of clothing doesn't
fit all so do not judge others Journey
without knowing more do not judge your
own life by looking at someone else's or
comparing your situation with someone
else's you are you and they are they
your life is your life and theirs is
theirs do take inspiration from their
journey in a way that you can enrich
yours no always remember life is the
most difficult exam many people fail
because they try to copy others not
realizing that everyone has a different
question paper how many of you breathe
I am sorry for asking that question how
many people breathing for the last
couple of minutes as I started this talk
I'm sure all of you have how many of you
are conscious of your breathing
mindful of your breathing I don't think
so any of us
how many of you use an Apple watch any
of you here
and do you know that on an Apple Watch
there's a facility which gives you
giving you reminders after every one
hour time to breathe
[Music]
yeah if you use an Apple Watch you know
that it gives you a reminder after every
one hour time to breathe and focus and
being mindful of your breathing ladies
and gentlemen
none of us in the last one odd hour of
shall I say through the day
have been conscious of our breathing
now imagine when you start breathing and
you just keep breathing in and in and in
and in and then can you live
no
and imagine if you start breathing out
and you breathe out and you breathe out
and you breathe out can you live
no can you imagine how life is fashioned
in such an incredible sophisticated
refined rhythm
the rhythm of breathing
when we talk about life we talk about
we're so unconsciously this taking in
and is giving out mistaking in and this
giving out if we just keep taking in we
choke up and if we just keep giving out
we choke up what an incredible balance
life has to teach us what an incredible
Rhythm simply our breathing has to teach
us
that life can't just be a life of takers
where we just keep taking kept taking
just taking or taking nor can life be
just
giving giving giving giving
the rhythm of breathing gives us an
incredible message
[Music]
take in
to give out
have to share grab
to care
that incredible balance that incredible
equation is what makes life
amazing I've done three talks in three
cities in India
I've spoken in Bangalore in India after
that was overcome to the airport go to
Chennai for another one finish that and
come back to Mumbai and straight from
the airport go to another event three
talk in three cities in a day what do
you if I snap well
you're technically right I did
but you're practically wrong ladies and
gentlemen
I don't snap like that
you can interact with me all the time I
don't snap like that
I'm a human body and a human machine in
your relationships ladies and gentlemen
I make a humble opinion to all of you
and beg of you life is short
it's very short
don't mess up with people
the closest people to you
give time to them
understand them
they may be you they may have said
something here and there and you may be
technically right okay look at the
Hidden Mango yes your husband or your
wife may not love you and that's
technically right
but there may be a Hidden Mango why
find that out before you brand them
your son or daughter may not listen to
you and you may be completely
technically right that they don't obey
you but find out the Hidden Mango why
are they doing what they are doing they
are doing that is clear everybody knows
it
it doesn't need two pins worth of Common
Sense is it a rocket science to
understand that
is a rocket sign to understand he's not
behaving right any damned fool can
understand it
it needs intelligence and maturity
tickle rightness it looks it needs
maturity and wisdom to start seeing
behind the scene to see why is this
person not loving me why is this person
behaving like that why is this person
not treating me right
and if you do that
believe me handle my heart your love for
whoever you love
will go so deep and your relationship
with whoever you relate to will be so
profound because it's based on maturity
not judgmentalism there are five levels
of people
on level one the lowest level
is a person who only sees bad in others
For Heaven's Sake that God just cannot
see any good
anyone here like that I don't think so
we're not so bad that we just can't see
any good some people just can't see and
you know it's like when you like someone
even if the guy does the biggest crimes
[Music]
don't like someone even does the good
best thing you don't like him
and if you have that experience if you
just don't like someone even if he has
all the good qualities you just can't
like him
there are some people on the lowest
level
they only focus on the bad they can't
see the good a level higher are those
who see the good and the bad but
conveniently ignore the good and focus
on the bad
how often it happens when we live with
people there's so many good things in
them but conveniently we neglect the
good things and only focus on the bad my
husband digs the nose okay
[Music]
he digs his nose but he also doesn't
mean how come you forgot all of the only
world
you saw that
how come you only saw that
you know we conveniently neglect the
good and focus on the man the third
category of people are those who see
good and bad
equally and they're neutral they're not
concerned good bad they're in their own
world
the fourth category are those who see
the good and bad
they choose to ignore the bad or deal
with the bad
and focus on the good
you want to like a person you have to be
on level four
if you want to like a person if you're
on level 2 where you're ignoring the
good and focusing on the bad how will
you like that person and how will that
relationship be deep
when you're on level four
where you choose to ignore the bad or if
the need be deal with the bad
and focus on the good and the fifth
level is
those who only see good that's God and
spiritually enlightened individuals who
will only see good in others anybody
here who's on level one only seeing bad
can raise your hand nobody okay thank
you anybody is here on level five only
seeing good if you raise your hand I
don't believe you oh sorry madam I do
believe you I'm sorry so I didn't see
you raise your hand I was just joking
sorry I I truly believe you madam I I
didn't see you raise your hand please I
just happened to save thinking nobody is
thank you madam we really appreciate can
you give a loud Round of Applause for
her my God amazing
okay now in your close relationships in
your close relationships how many of you
find yourself many times stuck at level
two
level two where you kind of look at the
bad
and forget the good that they have
thank you
in our relationships we need to come to
level
four you know when we're talking about
science and spirituality I I feel that I
never felt there is a divide or a
difference right
I feel the purpose is one
when we look at both having the same
purpose which is to unveil the truth
correct science is trying to unveil the
truth and spirituality is wanting to
unveil the truth so how are we different
in our purpose correct the methodologies
may be different
like in science I may use
[Music]
equipment I mean with instruments and
they use telescopes such as measurements
I may use so many different things to be
able to figure out what that truth is
correct and I will yes I will
phenomenally will correct so from
science and from all what I see
but I have facts not complete facts yet
which is why it's always evolving we
call it a relative science it's not an
absolute science mentalif's periodic
table right the values were changing
right we found out the truth later we
assigned a certain values and sorry sir
this is not what it is this is the
actual value so it's changing so could I
say that this is it may not be if I get
an instrument which is better than what
I have today I'll probably explore
another layer of that same facet right
now that's where I get the facts great I
need those facts when we talk about
spirituality it is giving the purpose of
those facts so we should be working in
tandem spirituality and science science
moment to work in tandem one looking at
unveiling the truth by giving us factual
data
one saying giving the philosophical side
saying what is the purpose of this data
correct what is the purpose of this
existence and both are two important
Dimensions to the same truth
you know so I I feel that's an
artificial divide it's an artificial
dividend and it's rigidity on both parts
both sides but we can't come together to
sit and say Hey look
I'll give you an example should a doctor
should a doctor repair a car
that's not a skill set
yeah should a car mechanic try and do an
open heart surgery
no so if I this is my area of expertise
let me do that much and not delve into
something further
let somebody else with this other area
of expertise come together and let's
pull it all together to unveil the truth
together
adding our own Dimension to it I want to
just offer to you three essential
principles of gratitude
being Mindful and grateful
the first one being
recognizing
all the wonderful things that have been
done to us
believe me we are in such a such a rush
most of the time we're not even
thoughtful and mindful to recognize the
incredible gifts that have been showered
upon us
how many of you heard loving parents
most all of us
how many of us feel that we've been
receiving so much affection from our
parents yes how many of you have loving
spouses you might want to or may not
want to raise your hands that is
completely up to you it's your choice
ladies and gentlemen whether you want to
raise your hands for this
how many of you had wonderful teachers
how many of you had some amazing friends
great how many of you have come in
contact with some wonderful spiritual
personalities
great and how many of us feel that our
life is a collective sum total of the so
many wonderful things that have been
done to us by so many in our lives
show off hands please
all of us isn't it so many of us have
been
recipients and received so much from our
families from our friends from our
teachers from Saints I'll tell you
something to be very honest
what the world needs today
is transformed individuals
we have a lot of affluence we have a lot
of influence
we have a lot of information
we are in an age which is laid laid in
with information
you know what we truly need
is transformed individuals who can
utilize what we have for constructive
causes in the world who can truly bring
light to the world who can truly bring
hope to the world there's enough
information what we would need is
transformation
and what better away
but to have a spiritual culture
to bring that transformational
individuals and in fact I don't want to
say it but I must but spirituality
happens to be one of those major ways to
bring transformation
I see so many people following different
parts of spirituality and change and
transform to not just be a part of
competition but be a part of
contribution
along with competition they're also
looking at contribution
youth is the Hope For The Wealth
youngsters young men and ladies are the
ones who can change the shape of planet
Earth who can change the way the world
functions bringing in incredible hope
and light to the world I must tell you
oh God
just how the world is when you're high
up you don't know what to say there
you're not just I was in America I was
just in America in February I was flying
from uh New York JFK Airport to go to uh
Detroit
and it was an airline called Spirit
Airlines
and in the morning they were selling
alcohol
so I asked the stewardess I guess your
airline is in very high Spirit you know
they were selling spirits in the morning
itself oh goodness
turbulence not in control
take off not in control Landing not in
control choice
in control
the takeoff of life is our birth
no control
I can't change my looks
I was born the way I was my name is
poor family some are born very smart and
handsome someone are bad so handsome
some Affairs some are dark some are
green some are yellow some are one in
the US some are born in Indian some are
born in America Hindu family Muslim
family some are born in Jain family some
are born in Jew families
what control do you have
over the takeoff did you choose your
mothers and fathers
do you have any control no control at
all and in the landing
death
and there's hope in life
God is the
you don't have to be hopeless failure is
not the end of the world someone
insulting you is not the end of the
world a Health crisis is not the end of
the world a divorce a breakup is not the
end of the world
and the turbulence is in your control
problems during the Journey of your life
from birth to death take off to Landing
as the Journey of your life goes there's
clouds there's wind speeds tremendous
turbulence which is completely beyond
your
control are people in your control
what people say about you behind your
back is your internal control
what people think of you is it in your
country you can try to be good but can
you control people
in New York when I was there recently
one guy came up to me after my talk and
said you're the egoistic person a most
egoistic person I've ever seen I don't
even know him
I am a human being
even I have feelings and emotions
can't just come and slap you on your
face and I won't even use the words he
used against me straight on my face and
then wrote a wrong email to me that
email is on my phone just in case you
feel I'm Live come and check out
God bashing me with words like oof
what can I do
when a Health crisis comes cancer
happens to someone for no fault of his
or hers
[Music]
you all know what can you do
what can you do
nothing right
therefore between this journey called
birth and death there's only one thing
in our control
our choices
the choices we make are completely
in our control choice
however take advantage of the time in
between you know and as I say when
you're born people love you
and when your people when you die people
love you in between you have to manage
spending how life is
foreign
dogs
he used them to punish all those
ministers who committed blunders one day
one of his ministers made a mistake
King was Furious and passed an order
that the minister be thrown to the dogs
Spirit to save his life the minister
pleaded your majesty I Faithfully served
you for 10 years and in return is this
what you would do to me
but if that's what you want fun you may
throw me to the dogs but before doing so
can you please do me a small favor
for 10 years of my service may I request
you to kindly grant me just 10 more days
before the dogs tear me off to pieces
King agreed to The Minister's proposal
the minister then approached the guard
who was in charge of caring for the dogs
and requested that the guard allow him
to look after them for the next 10 days
unaware of the king's order the card was
a little surprised why would a minister
want to do this but being delighted that
he would get a break the guard agreed
the minister had experience of caring
for wild animals from before he had
joined the king and so for the next 10
days he served the dogs with great love
and attention feeding them bathing them
cleaning for them and making them feel
very comfortable after the 10 days were
over the king ordered that the minister
be now thrown to the dogs
and it was done
Kings and everyone else's amazement the
dogs started licking the feet of the
minister being baffled by what was
happening the king asked what has
happened to these dogs why don't they
attack and kill this minister
before anyone could say a word the
minister instantly replied to the king
your highness I served the dogs only for
10 days and even in such a short term of
service
they did not forget
what I did for them
yeah I served you for 10 years and
you're very conveniently and easily for
God all that I did for you just because
of
one mistake that I made in all these
years
the king felt ashamed of himself and
Having learned a vital lesson in
personal dealings ordered for the
minister to be freed and accepted him
back in a service isn't it a fact that
as soon as there is a provocation or a
mistake made or a troubling situation
that comes up we very quickly forget all
the good that others have or the good
that others have done for us
gratitude is firstly about a sharp
memory memory of all the kindness
service and good that we have received
it is then about action reciprocation
showing our goodness by letting go of
the one-off blunders that may happen and
to positively continue our relationship
with others let us not wipe off the good
that others have done unto us because of
small mistakes
situations or incidents it could be fun
to once in a while revisit your
childhood days and relive them one day I
happen to see a remote controlled
helicopter someone had and decided to
give it a try
having lost practice of using a joystick
it was a little hard in the beginning
but in a few attempts I thought I was
becoming a pro in flying it it was then
that I remembered how a friend of mine
from London had taken me for a ride on
his private plane as we were taking off
I recollect sharing and inspiring quote
with my friends on that flight I had
said when everything seems to be going
against you remember that the airplane
takes off Against the Wind not with it
well the time he says now we were flying
in definitely gave us a real time
experience of that quote as it was super
wobbly during takeoff but we had a very
smooth Landing don't they say all is
well that ends well
recently I decided to try a real
Adventure a one in which you take off in
a plane but don't land in it
skydiving
the night before
in bed
visualizing myself jumping off the plane
thinking what if the parachute doesn't
open what if it opens but malfunctions
when we are in the air what if I have a
free fall
straight on the ground ladies and
gentlemen do you know what's stopping us
from taking the plunge do you know
what's stopping us from growth
towards what if what if I fail what if I
lose what if people mock me what if he
or she says no what if what if what if
what if life will pass away and our
minds will stop us from realizing our
truest and fullest potential that night
I decided to confront my what if and
shut my mind up I asked myself do you
want the experience of jumping off a
plane
yes came the answer from within
then know what else whatever happens be
ready for it I said to my mind
to make sure it was not an uncalculated
risk I decided to evaluate the risk
factor when I checked the statistics of
skydiving casualties on Google it was 13
fatalities in 3.3 million skydives last
year way less than the car accidents
that took place last year
but what if
I happen to be one amongst the 13 my
mind protested again that lie down here
in bed snoring and being a couch potato
missing the accelerating experience in
your life I told my mind as I drifted
away into sleep crossing the crippling
boundary of whatevs I remember telling
myself
look darling
you're skydiving support tomorrow is an
expert he has had several years of
experience with thousands of skydives
and not a single casualty was recalled
relax take it easy the next day as the
doors of the plane opened at 18 000 feet
above ground level I was ready telling
myself I want to do it I can do it I
will do it I remember standing at the
edge of the plane door now fearlessly
looking down and then
jumped
3-4 was the most liberating spirits of
my life Liberation from the two
paralyzing words
what if as we fluted in the air feeling
light like never before
parachute opened and I thought to myself
today the parachute is opened so has my
mind open your minds
face those things that are holding you
back
cross the limiting boundaries of your
whatevs believe me an amazing life Waits
ahead on the other side
of what apps tell you something
how many of you know this guy
I'm not too sure if you know him
this gentleman is one of the most finest
violent players on planet Earth
his name Joshua Bell
his violin costs 4 million pounds
[Music]
his violin costs that's the worth of his
while in Joshua Bell
Washington Post they decided to do a
experiment
they put Joshua well whenever Joshua
Bell would perform concerts
people would have to pay anywhere in the
range of 300 to 500 for an hour to
listen
ER concerts
you know they put him in a Subway
Underground Station put him on a subway
and asked him to put a simple jeans
t-shirt and put a cap so he stood in the
subway
and he performed some of the most
amazing gigs
as
that's how he played
incredible pieces masterpieces
and Washington Post did a research to
see
within an hour's time of his playing
how many people stopped by how many
people passed by him how many people
stopped by to hear what he had to play
and how much money did he earned coins
[Music]
one thousand
and 97 people
1097 people passed by during this music
that he was playing in the one hour in
the subway
ready to hear how many actually stopped
to listen to him
any wild guesses
seven people
out of 1097 people his concert Halls
would be full all the time seven people
stood there
and guess how much money he got in the
Hat a ticket
32 in one hour
and Washington Post
this
explode to say
what had happened it was the evening
hour everyone was in a
Rush
when you're in a rush
and you go too fast in life
you cannot have a spiritual experience
this is why
press a pause
[Music]
in your 20s to 30s every now and then
press ER
introspect
relish things in life
the best things to relish are the
simplest things in life not the
complicated for intense what really is
important is in the world today we are
talking a lot about Wellness
physical wellness is spoken about
mental Wellness is spoken about
emotional Wellness is spoken about I
don't hear a lot of people talking about
professional Wellness you know and when
we're talking about professional
Wellness I'm not just talking about
somebody who's doing well professionally
there's a difference between doing well
and feeling well right doing well is
your expertise that takes you to the
heights of your success and achievements
pays you well but feeling well is you
love what you do and you enjoy what you
do and a huge chunk of people out there
are doing well not sure if they are
feeling well so back in the day when I
was with hiblet Packard I was thinking
to myself that I'm doing well I'm being
paid well
but am I feeling well with my work I'm
going to have to spend 90 000 hours
doing this stuff
and there was a big fat no that came out
of my mind I I'm good at it but I don't
think I'm cut for this obviously the
next question that came in my mind was
then what am I cut for absolutely why
and that's when I realized that for me
my passion was not so much to work with
systems and machines as an engineer my
passion was to work with people to
explore life to understand life help
people with their lives the one way to
go about it was to probably study
psychology but then I also had a
spiritual College
so I thought why not explore my own
spiritual calling and see if I have
answers to life and dealing with life in
spiritual philosophy and wisdom which
can then help people as well but that's
what made me take that plunge and switch
over from or shall I say upgrade from
electrical engineering to Lifestyle
engineering whatever you might say it
you might say
and it's very fulfilling it's been 25 26
years no regrets so far touchwood it's
been very fulfilling the journey has
been incredible very satisfying I
also want to say one thing that I took a
risk yes you know when you take that
plunge leaving the secure and going to
the insecure moving from the certain to
the uncertain moving from the road
that's taken to The Road Less Traveled
all right do you take a risk and I feel
I took an uncalculated risk it was
uncalculated you didn't know what was
coming ahead
but when the passion inside of you is
burning so
powerfully it's like a guy in love with
a girl
it's burning so much it's irresistible
it's irresistible when I do tell people
I say that look don't take such kind of
risks though because you have real life
issues Financial liabilities mortgages
to pay terminally ill patients at home
often right and you you need to look at
that side and if you take that plunge
and just jump straight away into
following your passion just so that you
feel well that's right you may not be
able to address this real well
absolutely I I tell a lot of youngsters
who come to me for advice about writing
I say look that the early days when I
got into the world of writing I was
writing in the middle of the night but I
was still putting in a full day of work
and so my one piece of advice to them is
usually don't lose the day job because
it's very difficult to write when you're
hungry you know
but you did precisely that you quit the
day job I did it and that's what I wrote
advice
I'm saying keep keep your day job
who well so your financial needs are
addressed but also pursue your passion
and what you love to do so that you feel
well and maybe one day you feel well
will also be your mainstream profession
who knows how many of you could cook
maybe a little bit how many of you love
cooking
how many of your cooking is disastrous
foreign
[Music]
when you see all the ingredients of the
chunk
all the ingredients of the chunk are so
different and so diverse right right
temperature
you put salt
salt will give taste to the preparation
and always remain in the background
[Music]
foreign
but such diverse ingredients
[Music]
how relationship
don't expect your husband wife parent
child friend to be the same
diversity is what makes life beautiful
relationships are like that
[Music]
in India
in a place called Bihar
a small little place called Patna
there's a guy who studied in high school
there
and came out of Patna
to become a big business Giant
and once he returned back to Patna
and when he got back to Patna
he thought let me go
see one of my school friends whom I was
with in school studying for about eight
nine years
he went to see his cool friend the place
where his school friend lived was you
know small Narrow Lane so he's a
businessman now he couldn't drive in his
car so he parked the car outside decided
to walk into the lane
he heard that his school friend whom he
studied with for several years in school
had turned out to be a priest in a
temple
because his father was a priest
they're not met for a long time
so he went to see his friend who was now
a priest
and firstly the friend didn't even
recognize the guy you know he's a big
businessman still a priest and then they
kind of got up and started talking and
they started sharing their hearts and
catching up for whatever long time had
been going gone on and then this priest
looking at this new my friend would come
after a long time not even knowing what
he was not even knowing that he's a
businessman said to him
Hey look
you're not living in a big city
if just in case you want to do something
and start something and you need some
financial help
I've saved up this 25 000 rupees from a
long time
to give it all away to you to start
business this business
and this businessman was a friend
God his heart was touched with this man
all he has is 25 000 rupees
and these 25 000 Rupees is willing to
give it all away to me
this is it made such an impact on the
heart of this businessman
that on CNBC this businessman was being
interviewed by one of his friends whom I
just met this evening here right here
was interviewing this businessman
and after asking the sutras for his
success ask this businessman would you
like to share the story
and this businessman shared the story
with a grateful heart remembering
his memory hadn't gone weak he had
remembered that this guy had offered me
this 25 000 Rupees to start something a
venture and that's all he had
who with deep gratitude remembered this
man in his memory that he was off
willing to give
ladies and gentlemen gratitude is about
memory about remembering what people
have done for us but remembering what
people do for us how they come forth to
help us and so many have done that for
us if I get to be in front of every kid
in every school in the world even
the one thing that I would like to teach
or tell the students who are listening
to me is that we cannot go on Extreme
sides of the spectrum
one extreme of the spectrum
is Follow Your Passion be yourself
correct which is what I primarily Teach
as well like what Albert Einstein said
you cannot judge a fish by its ability
to climb a tree right you know you can't
judge a fish by its ability to climb a
tree that's the fish bites ability to
swim in the water okay now two things
happen in that case number one the fish
is effective in doing what it can do
because it's in its right habitat and
number two it's satisfied because it's
in the right habit correct put a monkey
in the water the monkey is miserable put
a fish in between the fish is miserable
put a monkey on Victory the monkey
achieves Excellence put a fish in the
water the fish achieves Excellence so
I'm one of the proponents I am a
proponent of this principle that we must
definitely encourage our kids to follow
their potential and follow their passion
but what happens often is we go on such
an extreme end of the spectrum
that the other side
but what the education system has to
offer is there are many good things in
the education system as well so if I
were to talk to the students I would say
let's find that balance finding best of
both the words you know grab the best
out of what you can have from the
education system and let the education
system also Foster a culture an ethic an
ethos you know where we allow kids to be
who they are reading inspirational and
motivational books and I also think
because the online world is so big today
the online platform is so big today
whether it's Facebook whether it's
Instagram whether it is Twitter whether
it is YouTube this massive platforms but
there's so much material available so
much motivational stuff available so
much inspiration available as soon as we
feel low we may have our choice speakers
we may have our choice gurus the men who
have Choice experts by listening to whom
we feel motivated by listening to whom
you feel uplifted by listening to whom
you feel energized
we should regularly on a proactive basis
listen
to
podcasts watch
videos
or read books
that can keep us going this is of course
not when you have when somebody goes to
the extreme end of ending their lives
can't read a book or watch a video there
but that did happen we posted a video on
Facebook this reposted a video this
morning where we were talking about an
individual who wanted to give up his
life in Cincinnati Ohio in the United
States of America he was a university
student and as he was in
that moment of committing suicide
hanging himself to his head in the nose
and there was a notification on his
phone and WhatsApp notification the guy
happened to see that notification it
happened to be one of the videos we had
made
and he watched those videos for four to
eight hours non-stop all online stuff
available from our channels
online
and decided
I shouldn't commit suicide
decided to keep going which is why I
think that the third thing to boost a
coping mechanism is to look at online
motivational material as well it's a
proactive thing to constantly keep
looking for good material so that we
feel inspired motivated challenges and
problems are going to be there for
everybody like I said earlier or we'll
be stronger to face that excuse me is it
okay if I sit here
you can if you like
are you all right I'm fine thank you
don't be a crybaby throw that book away
and come and play football with us come
here now prove yourself
does every guy have to play football do
men not write poems I'm sorry about what
these boys are doing to you adeo
classmates and what's your name I'm John
and yes these boys are in my class they
bully me all the time just because I
don't play football just because I don't
like sports just because I'm Different
is it wrong to be different huh not at
all we are all different our likes and
dislikes are different we're gifted in
different ways some can play sports some
can write some can sing and yet others
can act look at the toolbox John each
tool is so different each one serves
living such a different purpose what if
all the tools in the Box were Jack sauce
who would tighten the screws who would
put the nail in place
who would make the surface of the wood
smooth to finish the job the carpenter
needs the Jack saw the screwdriver the
hammer and the planer like the tools
they are all different and have our
respective roles to play and each of us
gets to show our talent when the time
comes and no one else can do what we can
no one can contribute in the unique way
that we can you love writing continue to
do so yes it's okay for men to write
poems or to cook or to dance if that's
what they love and if that's what they
are gifted with does that make sense
surely it does thank you so much for
your guidance sir you're welcome I must
continue my walk now have a great day
John and all the best with your writing
an artist once came to a King who was a
great admirer of Art and said
okay
if you give me a blank wall in your
Palace I can create a spectacular
painting on it just another young man
was present there said to the king your
majesty please allow me to work on the
opposite wall as well I am an artist too
the king asked the young man and what
would you like to make the man said I
shall make an exact replica of the
painting that the other artist makes on
the wall opposite to mine and I shall do
so without even looking at his work I
would request you to place a thick
curtain between the two walls so that
neither of us can see the others work
and also have guards to make sure
there's no cheating everyone in the
court including the King was intrigued
and the King decided to give both
artists the opportunity to show their
talent
the following day
thick curtain was put in place
both the artists started their work the
first artist brought paints and oils and
brushes that he worked with the second
one
worked simply with a cloth and a bucket
of water after a month the first artist
told the cake that his work was complete
and when the king asked the second
artist when would his work be done the
young man replied that he was done too
came to the Palace
tests
he was stunned by the spectacular
painting and gave the artist a hefty sum
as a reward
he then asked for the curtain to be
opened up
to see the second artist and met up with
the challenge of creating the exact same
painting without seeing it
the curtain opened and lo and behold on
the opposite wall was an exact replica
of the painting every single line every
single color every minor deity was
exactly as it was on the first war the
king rewarded the man with double the
amount of money but being amused
wanted to know his secret the young
artist replied it was very simple your
majesty I just polished the marble wall
every day until it showed like a mirror
to reflect the painting on the opposite
wall often people come up to me and
complain that they lack confidence that
they don't think they have any Talent
but they lack motivation and I tell them
that all of these are a part of you the
hard work
is cleaning the wall of your mind in a
way that what's hidden deep within you
your talent your positivity your
confidence your goodness is reflected in
your mind and thus in your actions and
then you can indeed achieve something
spectacular don't they say that the soul
knows how to heal itself the challenge
is to science the mind and one of the
ways to silence the mind's negative
chatter
to neglect it
sometimes a little child who gets just a
little hurt starts cry aloud if the
mother pays attention the child cries
louder
but if she ignores the child knowing
well there's nothing serious the child's
crying slowly dies down
clean the same way if we pay attention
to the negative chatter of the mind it
gets louder but if we try to ignore it
it slowly dies down and how does one
ignore that chatter by absorbing the
mind in positive energy reading hearing
or watching positive stuff
hanging out with positive people and
then
as the Mind becomes slowly cleansed
beautiful painting within you
will be reflected
on it a friend of mine is a great cook
one day he was making a preparation from
okra also known as her ladies finger in
some parts of the world I saw him wash
and clean each of the okra pods with a
lot of attention and affection I guess
because he loved cooking
to be honest I was impressed with how
sensitive he was even in his dealings
with
vegetables
as he was expertly cutting the okra into
equal sized pieces for his prep
he happened to see a hole in the top
portion in one of the parts
guessing that the particular pod was
spoiled I assumed that he would throw it
away
instead with meticulous attention and
precision he removed the top portion
from the part using his knife and after
checking that the rest of the Pod was
fine
continued cutting it to be used for the
delicacy he was about to prepare
I learned a very important lesson from
the simple interaction if there be a
hole in one of the pods some may but
many especially here in India will not
reject the entire part
they would carefully deal with the
spoiled part by removing it and use the
rest of the pod which is still in a
perfect condition
if we don't even reject and awkward
entirely just because it has a hole in
it and an okra pod is probably only a
few cents worth
should we reject
people and our relationships which are
priceless
simply because of some force that they
may have
don't human beings deserve similar or
better treatment ladies and gentlemen no
human being is perfect and will most
certainly have some defects and
limitations let us learn to follow the
okra principle in our relationships let
us not brand people and reject them for
their flaws let us accept them for their
good side and let us expertly and
skillfully deal with their weaknesses
uplifting them and helping them to give
their best isn't it sad that anyone
find the dirt in others be the one
that finds gold what does someone like
you do to Mary day how do you meditate
when I came to the monastery the
meditation I was taught was Mantra
meditation which is chanting on beads so
I chant to Mantra and as I began the
process I realized how
challenging it was
to be present
into the sound of the mantra
and to be totally
in a space in a zone of thoughtlessness
where there's nothing bothering your
mind and you're completely present
and listening to the sound and totally
absorbed you know in the sound I
realized that it was a massive uphill
task and I think it comes that the
challenge comes from the fact that we've
got so used to multitasking hmm there
are mind functions on 20 tracks so when
we're just on the meditation track there
are 19 other tracks to deal with yeah
you know you have your personal life you
have relationship issues you have
professional issues there's so many
things going and if it's just coming
from family
so much going on in the country there's
so much that's occupying our mental
space and when you actually want to get
onto the track of meditation by kind of
just putting all of this the back seat
it becomes practically impossible and a
lot of people tell me this when they're
trying to meditate this is what happens
to them and I share my journey with them
this is exactly what happened to me when
I started it's been 25 years now every
single day without one day's Gap one and
a half hours every day
and I and I tell them that it's not that
it's not a challenge today
it would be very high-headed to say that
okay I've reached a state of
Enlightenment when I sit for meditation
everything's kind of there and I'm
totally absorbed very high-ended I feel
to say that
but I did a few things that I feel can
benefit those who want to really get
into that a deeper state of meditation
I I look at meditation in two ways a is
the meditation meditation as in the
practice
and B is everything that we do in our
life as meditation you know and I prefer
to work more on everything in my life as
a meditation which feeds into my
practice of meditation but do not
neglect the practice you're not neglect
the practice for sure so uh I'll tell
you what I do for instance uh one meal a
day
I'll just eat by myself
two meals I take with my friends my some
of my monk friends we will discuss chat
eat one meal is just by myself
the reason being I want to be present
mindful in the moment to savor the
entire experience of touching feeling
smelling tasting that food I avoid forks
and spoons as much as possible because I
want to touch and feel that experience
of the food now the reason I do it is
because it just means no phones no books
nobody to talk to and just being there
eating
correct so what I'm doing is by just
eating that one meal by myself training
my mind to be in the present like we are
talking now this three meetings lined up
for me tonight and there's a restaurant
called candy and greens at Bridge candy
the family is a very close friend you
know so they've just opened up a new
rooftop Terrace I'm getting message
after message could you come down to the
evening for dinner right but it's not on
my mind
it's not on my mind nothing outside of a
conversation between you and me right
now is on my mind so why why do I do it
it's because right now I'm training my
mind to be in the present when I used to
be in the bathroom I would sing like a
big thing for me because earlier I would
sing a lot of Cinema and movie songs and
now I sing some spiritual songs bhajans
whatever and then one day I realized hey
wait a minute this is not right
because neither am I into the singing
nor am I into the experience of bathing
so if I'm singing I'm missing the
experience of bathing and if I'm bathing
I'm not into my singing so why am I
doing two things at the same time
I stopped singing
just focusing on the experience of the
water coming down my body and
experiencing that so to me these little
things through the day matter a lot to
me and I think that's a that's more of
meditation to me because then what I do
here feeds into my mainstream practice
of meditation and what I do here feeds
into the little things as well so it's
kind of a loop one feeding into other do
any of you remember using a rank in an
exam during a school or college days I
remember losing my first rank in a final
exam just by a couple of marks does
anyone remember losing a job opportunity
or a promotion at work and feeling very
low about it I'm sure some of you may
have recall losing in a sports event or
maybe losing a role in a theatrical
performance or maybe losing a sought
after position of power
what to speak of losing a relationship
or losing a dear one as much as losing
something or losing someone can be
painful disappointing and frustrating it
just happens to be a part of our real
life in this real world there are things
in life we end up losing but because we
didn't give our best or not because we
were complacent because there are forces
beyond our scope beyond our abilities to
control and it's very important that we
accept this reality never lose hope
the one thing that makes life a painful
audio is hopelessness a boy runs into
the room where you saw four lit up
candles Illuminating the space with
their soft glow the first candle spoke
to the boy I am the candle of Love there
was a time when things were used and
people were loved but today things are
loved and people are used to getting
those things nobody values me any longer
saying this the candle of Love went off
the second candle said I am the candle
of Peace in a world where everything is
being torn down to Pieces who values
peace and the second candle went off as
well the third candle turned to the boy
and said I am the candle of trust if
there be anything that's really hard to
find in a selfish world it's trust
what's the point in me staying lit up
the little boy started sobbing as he saw
the flame of the candle of trust
off and the room getting darker the
fourth candle spoke in every assuring
tone don't cry my boy I am the candle of
Hope as long as I am lit they'll never
be Darkness things may be dim but never
dark as long as I am lit you can pick me
up and light the other three candles of
love peace and trust and brighten the
room up again the boy wiped his tears in
with a smile lighting up his face lit up
the room as he lit the three candles
with the candle of Hope ladies and
gentlemen no matter what you lose in
life never lose hope how do people find
that thing how do you recommend when
there's a lot of family pressure on them
how did they find the thing I find a lot
of times it's an issue with the system
correct like for example
the industry
the corporate world is only picking up
people from the top rated universities
the industry is only picking up students
who have the best grades
now if you have people who have been
picked up based on your University or
based on your grades and your mom
and your academic performance
then guess what parents are going to put
pressurized kids with you better get
them up you better get the grades you
better get to the best university
correct and guess what the educational
institutions do it's a demand and Supply
system
if this if the demand of the industry is
grades and the parents are pushing to
get grades the Educational Systems are
driven to make kids get grades now
imagine if the industry changes in the
corporate world redefines saying we
don't hire Graves we hire passion we
hire kid we hire candidates for their
passion okay now what are the parents
going to say don't worry about the great
sir look at your passion
and what is the education system going
to provide how to look at your passion
okay it's a at the end of the day it's
about the demand and Supply really you
know so in terms of how it is a kid or
how does an individual figure that out
for himself or herself
number one is there is a voice room
within us correct
and there's a voice from within us
that's constantly resonating with our
soul saying I love this you know I may
be great at it or I may not be great
with it either whichever way but I love
this I'm an absolute love with this I
can wake up early in the morning to do
this and I can go to bed like late in
the night if I were doing this I know
that that's what it's really in sync
with My Soul you know now what happens
with that is sometimes it's multiple
things
is three four five different things for
people
right and now that be the case that be
the case then I think it's also over a
period of time we need to funnel it down
to narrow it down to that one thing it's
like it's like being in love right a guy
or a girl is in love with somebody
there's three four different people
they're trying and seeing and they're
kind of exploring which one person who
like really really strikes that chord so
one thing is to listen to your inner
conscience constantly people who are not
in tune with their inner radar are not
going to be able to find out what their
passion is if you're living a life only
catering to the outside demands and not
introspecting not going deep to listen
to your conscience and your inner voice
where's the question of figuring out
what the passion will be able to see
what resonates with your soul there is a
great need that all of us start
practicing spirituality spirituality not
only declutters our mind meditation
mindfulness chanting prayer doesn't
simply declutter of a mind of the
anxieties or pressures that we go
through of the stress they that we go
through and not only does it uplift our
Spirits when we feel low and depressed I
think a spiritual process gives us
tremendous resilience and gives us
tremendous fortitude gives us tremendous
Inner Strength to stand strong
in the midst of all storms
and therefore one of my favorite quotes
which I very often brought up in our
life sessions is pain is inevitable
misery or suffering is optional what
happens to us we can't stop that the
fact is beyond us
but how we take what happens to us is
completely up in our hands I think the
pudding I tasted before the monastery
was a pudding of great achievements okay
I've been a university topper
practically every semester I've seen the
best I'm a vocalist
I'm a guitarist so when you enter into
an auditorium full of people
you know start singing start striking
some chords on the guitar
academically you're doing well uh I have
picked up by card for a great job so
tasted the pudding of achievements
tasted the pudding of uh control Power
Power
tasted the pudding of uh people
respecting and bending down when you
were up there right you're popular in
that sense and then I come to the
monastery and it's quite amazing I
tasted the pudding of all of this and I
moved into the monastery with that
baggage with the dashram that here I am
a academic success here I am a corporate
success here I am a ABC XYZ and I come
into the monastery and you're surrounded
by 30 other monks
who are either the similar age as you
are older to you and each one of them
from excellent academic institutions
probably some of them were gold
medalists in their field had great
corporate experience and now spiritual
experience and when I entered into the
monastery the pudding I tasted first was
humility it was more forced humility
because you're coming with a baggage
that you're someone and you enter into
that space and you realized hey I
thought I was someone
and suddenly the whole bubble bursts
open it's cracking the bubble open you
know
and then I my with good training from my
Guru and the other monks around there I
learned how humility is such an
incredible quality for once spiritual
growth personal growth professional
growth
in any space you want to grow humility
is such an incredible foundational
premise you know because humility
entails that you kind of accept or you
say that I know that I don't know at all
you know true knowledge is knowing you
know knowing that you don't know at all
ego says I know it all and humility says
I know that I don't know it all humility
says I know I'm good at something but
I'm not the best of everything or
everyone in the world so I enter in
there and I realized there's so many
people around was way better
and that acceptance that they are better
paved the way to learning you know like
don't they say if you think you're the
best person in the room
or the smartest person in the room
you're probably in the wrong room I
think what's happening a lot with our
lives today is that we're living in a
very fast paced life
life has become very fast achievements
social media statuses you know how
what's a stereo status on social media
how we achieve in our professional life
it's so much about having
that we forget living you know
and life is not meant simply for having
having is a part of life correct but
living is what life is for but in the
process of having and chasing to have
more he forgets to live well you know
and therefore when we're talking about
this monk principle so we are talking
about this monk mindset we are talking
about making that choice and
prioritizing to live well and we're
going to talk when we talk about living
well we talk about making those choices
we choose to live well we choose to do
things and I feel that one of the
greatest assets that each one of us has
been gifted with is the power to craft
our life to choose to craft our life to
choose to uh sculpt our life we are The
Architects of how our life should be but
unfortunately we live so much in the
default mode like it's funny you know
when we're talking about uh iPhones we
don't keep our ringtones in the default
mode
we customize them when we wear clothes
we don't wear clothes that come in the
default mode we customize them even our
pizza toppings we customize them
so it's quite funny that we as human by
beings customize practically everything
we have and do but we live our life in
the default setting without customizing
it you know each one of us is different
each one of us has a different situation
in life each one of us has different
backgrounds different baggages we carry
and it's so crucial and important to
customize a life that's worth living you
know so one thing that I definitely want
to say people who are not going to go to
the ashram and nobody needs to bank code
is not about being in an actual
definitely need to look at prioritizing
how to customize their life and that's
then about making those choices every
individual has problems you can have two
people who go through the exact similar
crisis it could be academic it will be
Financial it could be professional it
could be emotional they go through the
exact same crisis one thrives
and the other
goes into a downward spiral of
negativity depression anxiety
frustration and I know problems can make
us utterly helpless we are helpless
sometimes after trying everything we
could to resolve those issues we know
it's a certain problems which are just
absolutely beyond our control and we are
helpless the problem is
not helplessness the problem is when
that helplessness leads to hopelessness
ladies and gentlemen it's not
helplessness that makes us depressed
it's not helplessness that makes us
frustrated it is that helplessness
that leads to hopelessness where we are
not able to see that Ray of Hope that we
are not able to see that ray of light we
are not able to see
the light coming at the end of the dark
tunnel that we are passing through it's
that hopelessness
that creates tremendous emotional
pressure on us and therefore what truly
differentiates to individuals
is there coping mechanism mental health
is about how do we have an internal
coping mechanism in a way that we don't
allow these challenges to get to us
let's not look at viewpoints from any
particular lens right
let us look at life and spirituality as
a process of learning right and when we
are talking about a process of learning
there's no Learning Without questioning
it doesn't matter what feed doesn't
matter what background if if
spirituality if religion is a process of
Education right and learning I'm not too
sure if education and learning would
happen without questioning in a dialogue
a dialogue right I remember I think was
it
it was Isidor Rabbi was his name
physicist that if I'm not wrong this
gentleman got a Nobel Prize Okay And the
reporter has asked him they said they
asked him said sir you are now a noble
Lord yet you have a Nobel Prize so what
made you different from all the children
in your neighborhood you come from a
Jewish background they Jewish background
from the judai tradition all friends all
from the same neighborhood
made you
you probably
need to be a physicist or a scientist
Isidor replied he said
they are doing exceedingly well and
they're doing very well they're still
amazing they're my great good friends he
said
and then he said
every single time all of these kids who
are friends who are in the same school
we studied in the same school some were
in the same class same grade
said when we came back home most of my
friends when they got back home their
mothers would
ask them
did you answer the question teachers
questions right today
and he said whenever I got back home my
mom said to me did you ask intelligent
and right questions to your teacher
today wow absolutely because education
learning is an evolution
and that evolution is not possible
without questioning right Reckless
questioning is something that we may
abandon absolutely you know Reckless
questioning meaninglessly is something
that Pete that all of us would agree to
that but genuine question questioning
for clarification for understanding
in fact I I tell people please don't
accept what I'm saying challenge me on
what I'm saying
challenge me because it's an education
it's the process of Educational Learning
otherwise it's Blind Faith right I'm
saying it so you're accepting it right
right so I feel therefore religion can
be questioned it should be questioned I
I'm not saying religion religion I'm
saying if it's a process of Education
questioning and learning must be a part
of it right if this is my academic
material education is my degrees I get
religion is meant to offer me spiritual
education and if it's a part of
spiritual education
how can education be without questioning
when you write
you will most certainly
end up making mistakes
what's truly great
is that
right behind you is attached an eraser
and you can actually
correct
that mistake
and
once again
right
the right thing
ladies and gentlemen
Even in our lives we make so many
mistakes
and what's amazing
is God has given us the opportunity the
chance
to erase them
to correct them and to rewrite our
stories
we all make mistakes I remember
I once went for a program and a
Gentleman came to me and said prabhuji
I'm your fan
I said why he said your talks are really
inspiring especially the jokes I said
what about the points man he said the
points are good but the jokes are great
I said to him come on all the jokes are
only meant to really pass on the message
and drive home the point
and just as we were talking a little boy
came running and I said your son right
he said yeah
and just following the boy came a lady I
said your daughter right
and the man turned blue
and the lady was like all smiles a year
to your smile because she was not his
daughter she was actually his wife
the guy turned to his wife and said
prabhujikujada seriously
oh my God I realized God I had made a
big mistake there by asking if it was
his daughter when she was actually his
wife we all make mistakes
now anyone who comes to me with people
around I never ask whether this is your
son or daughter or wife or father or
mother I just ask can you kindly
introduce me to everyone please
simple isn't it
yes we make mistakes
we should learn from those mistakes
erase them
correct them
and never repeat them everybody looks
solutions to problems isn't it
that's a big big thing that's stopping
us from experiencing happiness
that's a big thing that's stopping us
from making happiness happen who is it
that doesn't want to make happiness
happen
which problems that's nothing it could
be a health problem could be financial
problem
could be a relationship problem
could be a business problem
[Music]
stopping you from crafting your habits
we all want to do it all want the
solutions to this problems isn't it
there's no lock in the world that was
created without a key
not a single lock in the world was
created without a key I don't know why
would somebody make a lock without a key
and so every problem every challenge
every issue that's dead in our life
which is like a lock and seems like a
deadlock and Dead End
has a key
it's not seen now it's not visible to us
right now you don't know where the key
is
we are searching for that problems
how do you get a solution to the problem
you know what
every law comes with the key and every
problem with the solution
some of your problems can actually be
solved
and some of your problems
literally cannot be solved but can be
solved by becoming stronger to face them
that's the key
it's the key you know
what do you do when you have a mentally
challenged child born to you
[Music]
a child with special needs volunteer
what do you do
solution can't rewire things right
can't rewire things
but the solution then there is a
solution there is a key
this will change
the key is
you will have to grow stronger to faces
and solve that problem
Hannah
or is
[Music]
right because only two things you can do
run away
[Applause]
participate face it deal with it
shh
yeah
[Music]
which is why a lot of times I say
just because someone is happy
and just because someone is smiling
doesn't mean they don't have issues
doesn't mean they don't have problems
doesn't mean they don't have challenges
just because
[Music]
the difference
is they've chosen to deal with whatever
they can do with their problem they deal
with it but they've chosen to shift
their attention
to something else in their life
your attention is always on your problem
and only problems are in your mind
constantly just occupied by issues
problems challenges the difficulties the
troubles the emotional hurt the wounds
that have happened how are we going to
make happiness happen
with all of that going on you have to do
what we have to do to deal with it
when people smile and happy that doesn't
mean they don't have troubles life
they've just chosen
to shift
their attention
something that can make happiness happen
and both are exclusive one doesn't
cancel another a pampered boy you know
middle class family but only son I had a
younger sister but the only son from a
marwadi Jain family so you know like
really pampered everything I wanted was
given everything I asked for was right
there a kind of spoiled brat in that
sense you know I never ranveer I never
ever in my life ate me at home if it
wasn't made according to what I'd asked
for so I only ate at home
if what I asked for was cooked right and
I come here to the ashram to the
monastery
and
I can't choose my meals hmm
whatever is cooked in the community
kitchen and is served to everybody
I'm gonna have to eat that right and
trust me back in the day
didn't have enough money you know so
five days a week
they got the same vegetable the cheapest
one and that was the curry with some
rice and Dal
and initially my mind was like rebelling
come from a family it looked pampered
you know what I mean right yeah yeah and
then I come here and everything's like
I have to just just confirm I have to
just eat whatever's available
and then I realized
what did I come here for
did I join the monastery or the ashram
for luxurious fine palatable food
or did I come here for a purpose which
is much larger
than these little things around my life
and then the more I started tuning into
my sense of purpose something way higher
than these little things around I
realized that those things weren't
bothering me that much you know not to
say that they didn't bother me at all
that would be haughty to say that it
didn't bother me at all but they didn't
bother me as much because now my
attention
was on something that I came in here for
so I always tell people especially the
youth don't allow your minds to be
distracted from what your purpose is
what your goal is all what you go
through as in the ups and downs you
experience is only an outcome of taking
your eyes off your goal you know so the
lack of facility shouldn't depress us
and the presence of luxury and facility
shouldn't distract us so then there was
lack of facility today there is
abundance of facility in our Monastery
in our national we live in South Mumbai
downtown right we're surrounded by
luxury all over the place you know so
then back in the day there was nothing
and today there's so much but because
the attention
is on the purpose at that time I learned
from my training and from my experience
there that uh I could actually take a
lot in my stride because I kept shifting
my attention to what I was meant to do
which was what which was a to deepen my
own spiritual calling and B was to see
how to strategize to share that
spiritual experience with the world you
know so kept bringing my attention
constantly to that so if you want to
decode my learning
from this the monastic order my
spiritual path particularly for the
Youth say keep keep your attention and
focus constantly on what you're meant to
do in life which basically means there's
a need to discover what you want to do
in life if you haven't discovered the
smallest trivia can disturb you and if
you've discovered and you're focused on
that the largest setbacks can be handled
and you can take it in your stride
there's so much condition to doing
things the way the world does it there
are standards of what is success the
standards award a school that standards
of what's socially acceptable but but is
your life good have you chosen to live
that way or is that noise and that
influence making you live that way and
most often if not always
it has a lot to do with that influence
correct so I I'm not saying education is
wrong I'm not saying our upbringing or
the advice given by a family or our
friends or a well which is wrong I'm
just saying we cannot drown in that
noise
and lose ourselves it's our life it's
our life we are not going to live it for
us you know all those people who accept
us because we show ourselves in a
certain way on social media don't really
come there when we need them the most so
sometimes I say we prioritize our online
relationships so much that we forget our
offline relationships the real ones you
know when if I meet with an accident if
I'm if I'm Ill if I have an issue with
my my financially issue what if I wish
you a problem you know people online
they're good they're good those friends
on Facebook and Instagram people who
follow they're good absolutely good and
with all good intentions
the most they can do is send you a
message the most they can do is send you
a bouquet of flowers you know get well
soon messages and they're great because
the scent with love and intentions good
intentions they're great but people who
are going to be bare around us
other real people the real relationships
but in being accepted on social media
and being accepted by the social
standards of success which I call noise
we get so drowned in that noise that we
forget our voice so that's a
conditioning event you know that we've
got so conditioned to live like that but
we don't now want to customize which
basically means we have to come out of
the shell to come out of that Loop we
have to crack that condition and crack
that Loop ladies and gentlemen very
often we're just carrying and lugging
around all these problems anxieties
challenges frustrations in our head
and how long
can we handle them by ourselves
there is a great need that we
we give event to all of our thoughts
feelings frustrations anxieties this is
a great need that we speak up
and therefore I feel one of the greatest
assets we can have for great Mental
Health
is a very close friend
to whom we can speak a heart guys it
could be a girlfriend I know some of you
smiling girls it could be your boyfriend
I know girls you are giving a coin smile
men it could be your wife ladies it
could be your husbands it could be your
parents it could be your siblings it
could be a colleague
but someone who is a dear close friend
to whom we can open up if you find
yourself not being valued don't get
angry or frustrated know that you're
probably in the wrong place being judged
by people who see Tiny parts of you tiny
parts of your life not to hold you or
being judged by people who see you for
how much is your net worth how much is
your current market value they see you
for what you have not for who you are
look for those who go beyond all
externals who have the expert Vision to
see the true you beyond all your
shortcomings in all your faults those
who can see your true value your true
potential they will inspire you to do
well drink it well to love to grow and
to rise in life guys isn't it true that
every individual has a special sense of
worth all we need is someone who can see
that worth in US and make us see that
work in ourselves as well there's a
beautiful Sanskrit verse which says
there's no actual letter that cannot be
turned into a mantra
there's no plant root herb that is not
medicinal
purusham nasty there's no person who's
ayuga or unworthy but you know guys
what's lacking
what's lacking as an expert you can see
the value the worthiness and encourage
us on our paths in Mumbai it is my
favorite story I tell this all the time
I love it
in Mumbai India sometimes they do the
singing events kirtan I sing the holy
names of Krishna the Hari Krishna mantra
and sometimes we have like 200 students
all all youngsters all University
students and in this 200 students about
60 of them are PhD students it's amazing
all of these PhD students coming and
participating we have 200 of them all
University students and then I sing like
two hours I just sing
I speak but I also sing
and when I finish singing then all these
students will come and say that was
amazing
and believe me it's hard to take those
compliments seriously because they don't
understand any music
but anyway I I really kind of responding
I said thank you very much thank you
very much really grateful for your kind
compliment I take it because it's out of
love it doesn't matter on this killer
expert we're very loving so I say thank
you now one evening we had this kirtan
event
singing event
and a special personality came for this
event
it was the lady it was a lady she was 80
years old
every other everybody else is like
between 21 and 25 and there's only one
lady who's so elderly she's like 80
years old
and she happened to be the grandmother
of one of our students
she came and she sat there I mean what
what's so special if an 80 year old lady
comes and sits for the kids it's okay
she was trained in singing for 35 years
she came and sat there now that day if I
wanted the compliment of the word
amazing
it was from her if she said amazing sort
it
you sort it all these kids say amazing
who cares you know they don't understand
music anyways but a lady who's trained
to sing for 35 years she says amazing
you you made it you've done it
so so usually I sing with the harmonium
in front of me I call my eyes closed and
tight shot for an hour whatever I don't
open my eyes usually try to
that day every few minutes I was opening
my eyes to see how is she not doing is
she completely involved in the singing
because then you know that oh it's going
good
after the whole thing was over the kids
were coming and saying amazing I said
okay thank you thank you there's only
one person I need to hear one person
today the 80 year old grandma
who really has 35 years of experience in
singing
[Music]
mind actually and he brought his
grandmother to see me and the
grandmother came and as she came there
you know sometimes you say these things
in modesty
you don't mean it at all
like you how many of you said oh sorry
and not meant it at all
did you have you
okay thank you have you ever said a
thank you and didn't mean it at all
happens all the time isn't it but they I
said a statement
it was just artificial modesty I didn't
feel it like that I didn't feel like
that at all I just said I said to her
actually
I don't know how to sing well
and I'm actually off the key
in India they call it besoor
I'm off the Kima besuru she said that's
right
[Music]
oh my God
that's right
[Music]
I'm like
completely
devastated
but devastated
and I'm like thank you
how can anybody say it straight on your
face I mean you could say uh yeah it was
kind of something you can make you I
said I'm off the king that's right
grandson was standing right
shouting at her grandma
I mean he didn't shout that loud this is
exaggerated he's a grandma
did you hear what he's saying he's
saying he's off the key he can't sing
well
she said that's impossible
if he was off the key and he can't sing
well I wouldn't have sat here for a
single minute
now I was confused
within one minute just now she said I
can't and now she says I can
and then the grandson turned towards me
he said prabhuji she's hard of hearing
she uses a hearing aid
and she didn't bring it today
so because your singing was Amplified
she could hear but when you're talking
she can't hear
and therefore sometimes she just has to
say that's dangerous you just keep
saying
to anything that anybody says
now believe me if I would have judged
her by her actions
I would have for my life thought that
and branded her by saying what a
horrible woman she doesn't know
etiquette and you know sensitivities in
dealings
but when you look at the Hidden Mango
behind
which I didn't know
which is why until you know
don't judge
until you know don't brand
until you know don't come to a
conclusion there was a young man who
tried his level best to clear his exams
at University
but he repeatedly failed and finally he
just gave up
thinking that marriage would be the best
way to make him responsible his family
got a married after the marriage the man
took up a job as a primary school
teacher
but due to lack of experience was mocked
by the students and finally removed by
the school authorities in just a few
weeks time
when he returned home that day
his wife wiped his tears and converted
him she said to him you can teach young
kids only if you've taken formal
training or at least have some
experience of teaching gifts and for you
you didn't study teaching at University
nor have you dealt with kids earlier so
how do you know how to teach kids don't
be too sad about it when God says yes to
your prayer he gives you what you want
but when he says no to your prayer
here's something better for you probably
there is a better more suitable job
waiting for you out there Gathering some
hope the man kept trying to find
Opportunities and when he did finally
find one
once again chucked out of the job due to
slowness yet again his wife tried to
encourage him by saying I'm sure there
are people who are skilled and
experienced at that job and their
experience comes from many years at it
as for you you were in school trying to
teach kids all this why so how could you
acquire the needed skills
don't worry when God says no to your
prayer he gives you something better
but when he says wait to your prayer he
gives you the best the man kept trying
his luck with several jobs which never
lasted more than a couple of weeks at
best months
each time he would return back home
dejected and depressed and his loving
wife
would comfort him never once was she
disappointed or resentful by the time
the man was in his 30s he'd found his
calling and had acquired a flare in
languages he ended up being a counselor
in school for those kids who were
challenged in hearing and speaking
and a little later he opened his own
school for specially abled kids in a
couple of years he set up a chain of
stores in different cities and provinces
selling apparatus and equipment for the
specially abled and went on to become a
multi-millionaire
the Now Rich Man asked his wife
when I was so negative about my own
future
how could you have so much faith in me
the reply that his wife gave him was
simple yet very profound and inspiring
she said when a piece of land is not
suitable for planting wheat we should
try planting beans and after all the
years of efforts if beans are not
growing well we should try planting
fruits or veggies and if the vegetation
doesn't work we can scatter buckwheat
seeds these seeds will one day blow
flowers and on the very land self
once
seed that will germinate and grow
after having listened to the wife's
explanation the man wept her faith in
him her love her patience her
persistence
actually responsible for the successful
Empire and they now owned ladies and
gentlemen no one in this world is
useless the land may be very fertile but
you may not have figured out your seed
yet it takes a while to figure out
what's your seed what works for you but
once you discover your seed your passion
your calling excellence and abundant
growth will simply be a consequence
until then you need to
yourself more so you need someone who
can believe in you
keep you going
to Lucy
your day yoga is a process that goes
even beyond the mind to connect your
very essence to your very self and to
connect to the Divine and to divinity
and that spiritual dimension of yoga
can lead to a very
powerful
contribution
that's called selflessness
the process of yoga spiritual
purification leads to selflessness how
many of you love ice cream
okay thank you but there's a problem
with ice cream there it's fantastic to
taste ice cream the issue with ice cream
is its ideology the ideology behind the
ice cream is enjoy it before it melts
and the thing is life is such as well it
melts away
and people who believe in the ideology
of the ice cream say Enjoy your life
before it melts a very selfish ideology
narcissistic and self-absorbed
contrast that with the candle
what is the ideology behind the candle
give light to others before it melts and
ice cream melts and a candle melts
but an ice cream is all about
narcissistic self-absorption and a
candle is about selfless contribution
ladies and gentlemen it is time now
that we need to help ourselves and
people slowly make that shift from being
an ice cream
to a candle the more we stop living as
an ice cream and the more we start
living as a candle
we will think about the ocean
we'll think about the polar bear
we'll think about some little girl in
Syria
we will think about someone out there
because we are not self-absorbed we're
trying to be a candle to look at how we
can offer a solution to these issues
you know something the first letter of
the word illness
is I
and the first two letters of the word
Wellness are W and E which is we
and it's quite fantastic that when we
move from I to we
illness turns into Wellness ladies and
gentlemen it's very easy to make a buck
difficult to make a difference but
together we can all indeed make a
difference in our way
our tiny bit step by step and contribute
towards
dealing with the issues of climate
change and other issues that the world
confronts today and yoga can be such a
massive step towards it the philosophy
of yoga
teaching us sensitivity
the practice of yoga teaching us
self-control and the process of yoga
bringing us to selflessness the three
p's leading through the three s's when
we connect them all that's yoga for
climate change I had a personal
experience when I just joined the
monastery about 24 years back
in India when we joined monasteries even
in homes we didn't have laundromats and
washing machines we just had the
traditional Indian way of doing our
laundry we would have detergent in water
and we would soak the clothes for about
30 minutes and then after 30 minutes we
would rinse them in another bucket of
clean water that was just how we did it
so I came to a monastery obviously and
we didn't have a laundromat and up until
then I was 21 when I joined the
monastery up until then the laundry was
always done by my mom
so here I was now in the monastery never
ever
did my laundry and I'm confronted with
this orientation now of learning how to
do my laundry so I learned it and one
day I remember I had to go for an event
I soaked my clothes into detergent and
water for 30 minutes and then I went to
the bathroom now to rinse them in
another bucket of clean water
but being a little lazy of who's going
to bend down to pull the water pull the
bucket under the water faucet I kicked
the bucket
under the tap under the water faucet and
then I Heard a Voice of someone from
behind me asking me what are you doing
I suggest filling in water to rinse my
clothes
this elderly monk said to me oh I can
see that but what are you doing
I said I mean I'm just rinsing my
clothes
he said I can see that but what are you
doing
I mean being a little shocked at the way
he was
bringing this up I said what are you
hinting to he asked me why are you
kicking the bucket
I said look
it's a bucket not you
why are you so concerned and why are you
so bothered about just a bucket right
he said to me
it's not about a bucket
it's about an attitude of insensitivity
if you treat your things insensitively
you will end up treating people nature
the resources on the globe insensitively
as well start with the smallest things
in life
and you will see how that attitude
starts percolating in the larger things
of life as well a man walking on a road
in a small town
found a piece of paper tied to an
electric Pole the paper had a small note
written on it and so curious to know the
contents he went closer and read what
was written there the no trade
I'm a poor woman and I've lost 50 rupees
somewhere around here on the road if any
of you happen to find it could you
kindly bring it to me at this address
due to a very poor eyesight I can barely
see so please help the man followed the
address and found an old dilapidated
heart with a much older lady sitting
outside
as she heard the sound of his footsteps
the lady who looked really weak and
frail asked who is it the man replied as
I was walking on the road nearby I found
50 rupees there and then happened to
read the note that you put up on the
electric pole so I came over to hand
this money to you
hearing this the lady began to weep and
she said Dear Sir at least 30 to 40
people have come over to give me 50
rupees saying that they found it on the
road and that they read the note on the
electric pole well trust me I didn't
write that no I cannot even see properly
nor do I know how to read or write
okay
please keep this money and get something
for yourself said the man
as he was about to leave the lady asked
him to tear that note off on his way
back
as the man walked back he wondered about
who could have written that note and
certainly she would have asked every one
of the 30 to 40 people who had come to
bring her the 50 rupees to tear that
note but none had done it
the man mentally thanked the person who
had written the note and thought to
himself
if one truly wants to help someone in
need and makes an attempt
so many more come forth to join the
chain of kindness and make a positive
difference it takes one person's genuine
will to help and then there is always a
way as the man was walking back his
Spirit uplifted by the positive energy
and the joy of serving another man
walking by stopped him and asked
you help me with this address I just
found a 50 rupee note and want to hand
it over
let us be grateful for being blessed
with what we have and let us try and be
instrumental in Sharing even a tiny bit
of what we have with those who are not
only in need but are utterly helpless
let kindness and love spread in the
world and let Humanity
be the ruling force a lady who was over
90 years old but had a great Flair
towards dressing up well applying makeup
and arranging her hair in beautiful
patterns she and her husband had been
married to each other for 70 years after
the departure of her beloved partner
having no children and no one in the
family to care for her she decided to
move to a nursing home
even on the day when she vacated her
home for good she dressed up eloquently
and looked gorgeous after arriving at
the nursing home she had to wait
patiently in the lobby for hours before
her room was ready when an attendant
helped her make her way to the room she
gave the lady a visual description of
the tiny space that she was meant to
occupy I love it the lady expressed with
the enthusiasm of an eight-year-old who
had just been presented with a new puppy
Mrs Jones you haven't even seen the room
yet just wait the attendance remarked
well my joy has nothing to do with the
room the lady replied whether I like my
room or not doesn't depend on how the
furniture is arranged it depends on how
I arrange my mind happiness is something
you can decide ahead of time and I've
already decided to love my room to love
the people around me to love my life it
is a decision that I make every morning
when I wake up you know what the
greatest asset we all have is the power
to choose how we feel the lady continued
speaking as the attendant listened
attentively with her mouth wide open
I can spend my entire day in bed
thinking of the pain I am in focusing on
those parts of my body that no longer
work or I can get out of bed and be
thankful for those parts that do work
each day is a gift and as long as my
eyes can still open I will continue to
focus on today and all the happy
memories I have stored in my mind just
for this time in my life the attendant
was astounded by the positive attitude
of the elderly lady whose life from an
external point of view is only full of
problems and hopelessness ladies and
gentlemen
only problems happen automatically
happiness is a choice we all have to
make only anger happens automatically
peace is a choice we all have to make
only hatred happens automatically love
is a choice we all have to make being
negative happens automatically a
positive attitude is a choice we all
have to make complaining is automatic
gratitude is a choice we all have to
make
choose right and Live Well two guys
graduated from University together and
after a couple of months joined the same
company after two years their manager
promoted one of them Rahul to the
position of a senior sales manager but
the other one jiten remained in the same
position as he had joined a sales
officer chitin felt hurt disgruntled and
even felt jealous of Rahul since he
needed the job however he continued
working anyways after a couple of months
jiten's bitter feelings towards Rahul
grew so much that he just could not work
with him any longer he wrote his
resignation letter but before he handed
it over to the manager he complained
that the management did not value
hard-working staff and that they
promoted only the ones they favored the
manager was well aware that Japan worked
very hard for the company even harder
than Rahul and thus he much deserved the
promotion but something was missing
so to help jitane the manager gave him a
task can you go and find out if there's
anyone selling watermelons
returned and said yes there is a
watermelon seller the manager asked how
much is a selling price per kg jiten
drove back to the top to find out and
then returned to inform the manager that
the winter was selling the melons for 13
rupees and 50 paise per kg the manager
told you they let's give Rahul the same
task and see his response so in the
presence of jiten the manager said to
Rahul can you please go and find out if
anyone is selling watermelons in town
Rahul instantly left and on his return
he reported to the manager sir there's
only one person selling watermelons in
the whole town the cost is rupees 49 per
watermelon and rupees 32 and 50 paise
for half a melon he sells them at rupees
13 and 50 pesos per kg when sliced he
has 93 melons in stock each one weighs
about 7 kgs his farm can supply us with
melons for the next four months at a
rate of 102 melons per day at 27 rupees
per melon inclusive of delivery charges
the melons are excellent in quality
appear fresh and red and taste way
better than the ones we saw last year he
also owns a slicing machine and is
willing to slice for us free of charge
we need to strike a deal with him before
10 AM tomorrow if we do make this deal
we'll surely beat last year's profits
and melons by rupees 223 contributing
positively to our overall performance as
it will add a minimum of 3.78 to our
current overall sales Target I have put
all this information down in writing and
is available on a spreadsheet please let
me know if you need it as I can send it
to you in 15 minutes
[Music]
impressed by rahul's smartness and
inspired by his commitment he realized
the difference between himself and Rahul
he decided not to resign but to learn
from Rahul there is in general it's not
what we do but how we do that makes us
different and stand out from others it's
not about doing things but about going
the extra mile that brings us the reward
it's not merely hard work but smart work
that gets us there it's not about
looking at others but about looking at
oneself that brings us existence
next time you find someone else doing
better than you
play
put your act together
your homework
[Music]
extra mile and then maybe fast or slow
success will surely be yours they say
Pride cometh before the fall you can
make things as big you can be as
successful as ambitious
but when there is pride
[Music]
how to crush that right in the powder
you know I mean I I have been a speaker
for years now
and sometimes you know I give talks and
people are like sitting and hearing and
most time people come and say
s
this is what I give the talk for
but there was one man one man came up to
me and said I said to me
hate your lectures
[Music]
eat your lectures
so I asked him you hate me he said
look at this guy
I went to my college College of
Engineering Puna he was from there
he was one of the alumni so there was an
alumni program I was invited as a
keynote speaker I went for the speech
I was all prepared for what to say all
my notes were there my mind was prepared
my words were there I had already
visualized myself standing at the tires
speaking how the students would always
visualization was done so it wasn't it
was peanuts I've been doing it all my
life
I'll tell you something
that day
that day this guy was sitting at the
back way back in the program and he was
standing up and hearing my talk and just
two three weeks back he had told me I
hate your lectures
I tell you
it happened several times but this time
the Fiasco that I did in my lecture
you cannot imagine
everything was here I knew everything my
lecture notes were all there
speak spoke something of course students
didn't detect after 15 18 years of
speaking
but for me I knew I wasn't together
we feel you
when I came back in Spooner on my return
in the car two students alumni were with
me is talking to them what could have
been the reason for this myself
[Music]
it's no problem doing big things
ambitious things successful
Titanic success but when there is pride
that success is a failure you know with
pride success is a failure and with
humility and apparent failure is a
success because you can come out of that
failure yoga is an incredible science
that helps us transform a physical
fitness
which is what it's largely known for
today
but beyond even physical fitness it's
that science which can help us enhance
our mental Wellness
but I think even Beyond mental Wellness
yoga is a science that facilitates
the deepening of our spiritual awakening
but to be honest More Than Physical
Fitness more than mental Wellness More
Than A Spiritual Awakening
yoga is a tradition a culture a set of
values a set of beliefs that can truly
help us
deal with much larger issues in the
world
than Fitness maybe climate change or
maybe issues that are being tackled by
the 17 sustainable development goals of
the United Nations poverty hunger gender
equality education life on land life
underwater whatever these sustainable
goals may be
yoga has a solution a proposed solution
to deal
with these larger problems and
challenges that the entire world
confronts today I know that as soon as
we hear the word yoga as a solution for
Global issues
we're skeptical
how can a system of exercise
how can a system of breathing
be a solution to Global issues and
problems
which is why I very strongly and firmly
believe that we have to start thinking
about yoga as more than exercise we have
to start thinking about yoga as
dimensions
which has
the tenets to offer us solutions to our
Global problems
I was in London once walking and walking
at SoHo streets the Oxford Street near
so square and one gentleman British
gentleman came up to me and said is that
your favorite color
because everything's orange yeah I said
I guess so I didn't I didn't of course
want to explain to him the deepest
significance of it when he didn't want
to know yeah he just wanted to know if
it was my favorite color I said yeah I
guess so I think orange
represents uh flames of fire you know on
one hand it represents flames of fire
and in the Hindu tradition when somebody
leaves this world they're cremated the
body is kind of burnt consumed by the
flames of fire so donning saffron on
actually means that I am dead to my own
personal interests it's like these
flames of fire are consumed my own
selfish interests and now on my life is
meant to be for the betterment and
Welfare of others it's like you're
killing your own ego killing your own
ego yes and it's kind of now living for
brothers so that's what is meant to be
of course it's a lifelong journey to
live by it but that's what it signifies
the other aspect of saffron also is like
uh you have saffron as in case sir you
know the saffron strands so you take
saffron strands if you've ever added
saffron stand for prep you usually kind
of first roast it a little bit on a pan
in a pan to take the moisture off and
then you take a little bit of milk and
crush it hard in that little tiny bowl
of milk and it starts leaving all the
color and the fragrance and the flavor
and then you add it to whatever prep
like a whatever prep you know just add
the saffron to it so uh if you compare
someone's life to saffron the strands
then it also means to be a little bit
crushed a little bit roasted a little
bit by life to be able to add color
fragrance and flavor to the lives of
others you know so that's what it really
means of course a long way to go to be
able to live like that but that's what
it's device yeah Israel has two famous
lakes the Dead Sea and the Sea of
Galilee the Dead Sea is a lake with very
high salt content as high as 35 which is
almost 10 times the normal ocean water
such a high level of salinity not only
means that a human body can float on the
surface of the water but also that there
is no life at all in this Lake no fish
no vegetation no sea animals nothing
lives in this Lake and that's how it
gets its name the Dead Sea just to the
north the Dead Sea is the Sea of Galilee
yet completely unlike the Dead Sea the
Sea of Galilee is pretty resplendent
with abundant colorful marine life lots
of plants lots of fish in fact the Sea
of Galilee is home to over 20 different
types of fishes and guess what
both the lakes are in the same region
and both resene water from the very same
Source the River Jordan yet while one is
full of life the other
is dead the question obviously is how
not sure how technically correct this is
but some say the reason is because the
River Jordan
flows into the Sea of Galilee and then
flows out the water simply passes
through the Sea of Galilee in and then
out and that keeps the lake healthy and
vibrant female marine life but the Dead
Sea being far below the mean sea level
has no Outlet the water flows in from
the River Jordan
it does not flow out and since there are
no Outlet streams it is estimated that
over a million tons of water evaporate
from the Dead Sea every day leaving it
salty and too full of minerals and thus
unfit for any marine life isn't life
very similar like the two Lakes receive
water from the River Jordan we may also
be fortunate enough to receive resources
knowledge love respect from others but
if we do not learn to share what we have
received we may end up like the Dead Sea
the love the respect the resources the
knowledge could all evaporate but if
like the Sea of Galilee we share what we
have we will be full of life and joy
ready to receive more and share more and
live in a space of abundance comparison
leads to envy and insecurity and
insecurity and envy leads to dirty
competition competition when it's
healthy now no problem competition to
excel yourself you compare yourself with
your previous corner
why you're comparing yourself in another
score last year this is what I got let
me compare myself my current score how I
should improve now
but no we're so concerned about what
others do then I do
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
one-on-one with sad Guru check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there you invest your life in trying
to change the past this is like banging
your head on a wall which is not going
to break anyway your head which will
break what you can change you do not
change what you can craft